okay Mike Podium check
online and then we have Mike one
online and then we have Mike two
online and then we should have Mike
three online on
YouTube
do I still see the
captions
okay this is still the mic check for the
gfn workshop do I have any captions on
the
screen
they might
know
mik
one
start very
l
at least the first two days
yes
okay M check YouTube
M
check mic check
for
hey not P mic check
m
that
light
you're
[Music]
you
so
I
yeah
spe
you
EX
think
be
that
it's
she
spe
I me I know I
know
yeah
Mike two
hello Mike one
B
Pam and mik
three
hold your mic
one and
two and three
that
f
by
why am I I
yes I
didn't
e
you
might
it's uh it's
on it's on the website and we're going
to put it on zulip
too
hello
refresh
go
I
sorry
he just uh he just told
me okay wonderful yeah
I
what
take me a
while
what
don't
to
did you see
the
oh I
need
for week
like
that
I
um
uh
now
right hello
okay morning
everyone uh we're a bit late but uh that
should have been expect expected uh
we're going to get
started um so thank you for being here
I'm glad to see so many people on a cold
Wednesday morning I'm Victor Schmid I'm
a final year hopefully a PhD student
here at Mila with Yosh penjo and I will
chair this three-day Workshop um we've
designed the workshop to be very gradual
uh focusing on the understanding of
gonets and why you their the motivation
why you need them rather than EXP
exporing the the frontiers of the
ongoing research as you may already know
gonets are armatized vational inference
algorithms that are trained to sample
from unnormalized Target distributions
over compositional
objects all right if none of that madees
sense to you or only partially that's
fine that's actually why we're here
today so don't worry um tomorrow we'll
delve into the theory with opening words
from from Yeshua um stuck with me today
um and on Friday will discuss uh
practical applications and challenges
with uh training
gonet each day will be chaired by a
different researcher who has been in
charge of Designing uh that day's
curriculum so I want to thank them and
the whole team in general for making
this Workshop happen um a few months ago
when I started to get more serious about
gonets I saw two options uh either read
the papers or organize a workshop and
have the authors explain them to me
so uh here we are um a few logistical
details uh don't lose uh your badges
you'll need them tomorrow and the day
after um we have set up a zulip chat
room uh you've seen
that all right that was up uh so scan
the QR code and that chat room will be
where we can post uh papers references
where you can discuss uh and have
questions
online um importantly the first two days
of that of this Workshop will be
streamed on YouTube the link is on zulip
on M social media and it will stay there
if you want to access the recording
later
on if you need uh anything feel free to
reach out to any of us with this black
T-shirt uh we're the organizing team and
we we'll try to help you um not all
talks will take questions but for those
who uh do take questions if you have
something to ask please do use the mic
in the alley and there's another one
over there so that everyone can hear you
especially
online um something that is not a
logistical detail though is uh to
understand and acknowledge the history
of the land that we are on and so I will
read a paragraph to that effect so we
would like to begin by acknowledging
that Mila is located on unseated
indigenous lands the ganen Gaga nation
is recognized as the custodians of the
lands and Waters on which We Gather
today joj or Montreal is historically
known as a Gathering Place for many
First Nations today it is home to a
diverse population of indigenous and
other peoples we respect the continued
connections with the past present and
future in our ungoing relationships with
indigenous and other peoples within the
Montreal Community Mila acknowledges the
systematic barriers that indigenous
peoples face with respect to education
employment land and Technology
indigenous knowledge and science have
typically been devalued excluded and
erased from AI science
and we therefore recognize the need for
a commitment to work with indigenous
peoples in AI research and
Science Now that we know where we are
and where we're going uh let me welcome
the chair for our first day today
trist uh trist is a final year PhD
student working with yoshu Benjo he's
one of the core contributors of gonets
and is's leading the work on applying
gonet for caal Discovery at mil you can
stand back
up
all right thank
you yeah
perfect oh okay um yeah thank you thank
you uh Victor um so yeah my name is
Tristan I'm going to uh chair part of
the part part of this uh this first day
which is about introductory materials so
as Victor said we wanted to make this
Workshop as accessible as possible for
everyone for with various backgrounds so
we don't want to assume anything uh so
maybe this uh the things that we're
going to talk about today is going to be
very basic for uh many of you uh but
this is really on purpose so we're going
to start gradually with a first
presentation on really introduction to
probability uh and then uh going through
probabilistic modeling probalistic
inference so these are maybe things that
you've seen and then uh in the afternoon
we're going to look at um some of the
things that are more related to uh what
we've been uh what geonets are actually
used for uh so essentially sampling and
also some um some connections with uh
the reinforcement learning literature
which you might be uh familiar with uh
and you may know that gon it's taking
some inspiration from uh from
reinforcement learning unfortunately we
won't have this uh this last session the
the Practical session uh due to uh
technical reasons um so we will uh just
stop at around 3:30
today um so that being said uh I want to
uh
introduce our first Speaker who is
Victoria barin pel uh so Victoria is a
PhD student with simos julan here at MAA
and University of Montreal uh she's also
a visiting researcher at meta where
she's working with Pascal Von and she's
broadly interested in the topic of
causal representation learning and she's
going to talk about introducing us to
the realm of probabilities so please
welcome Victoria on
stage good morning thank you k for your
introduction um yeah so as Kon mentioned
I will kind of give an introduction C
probability maybe directed towards
someone from outside of the field or
maybe for some of you it's going to be
just like a simple review or recap of uh
basic
probability uh so yeah it's going to be
kind of informal don't expect anything
too rigorous but hopefully it will be
helpful
um so first although this is a can you
hear me well if I speak from good um uh
so this the theme of this lecture is
Introduction to probability but it's
also a little bit about statistics and I
want to talk about uh the difference
between probability and statistics
because that's what we're here for maybe
machine learning is a little bit more
like statistics so in probability you
have a probabilistic model and the
question you're asking is uh let's say
like I'm tossing a Dy and I want to know
the probability of getting uh number
one uh on the other hand statistics is
more like the inverse problem where you
have the data and you're trying to learn
the publicistic model or the parameters
uh so basically you can have like a Ser
series of uh um coin tosses and from
that you want to determine like uh if or
D was biased or not or what is the
probability of getting each uh each of
the numbers
uh so here is the plan of what I'm going
to present I'm going to start with
random variables probability density
functions and probability Mass functions
I'll give some examples of uh typical
probability
distributions um I'm going to present
General probability Concepts like
conditional marginal uh sum rule product
rule and the base theorem and then in
the end I'm going to drift a little more
towards statistics and talk about uh
maximum likelihood estimation and uh
based on
learning so let of random
variables uh basically random variable
can take different values uh from a set
and each of these values is associated
to a
probability uh if you have discrete
random variables it means that um your
variable takes integer values um for
example if you're rolling uh a number if
you're rolling a die your X can take
values between one and six but not like
1.5 and the probability of um each of
these values that you can take uh if the
the D is unbiased is going to be the
same for all of them one
say and here we call that the small X is
the realization of of X of the random
variable X
um and this can be represented for
example by a table where you have the
probability for each value that you can
take
or
um oops or by a plot like this which is
the plot of the probability Mass
function or a pmf so the pmf is the
probability defined for discrete vales
and well this is not just like a general
function since the probability has a few
properties for example the probabilities
are always uh non- negative so the
probability is between zero and one
usually and it cannot be minus
0.5 and the probability across all the
possible values that it can take will
sum up to
one
uh so this is basically uh basic
definitions but it can we can make this
like slightly more complicated and talk
about uh obtaining values within a
subset of your domain so let's say you
don't want to get the probability of
getting just one but the probability
that the V of the die will be two or
four or six and since this is an or kind
of op information you're just summing
this probabilities so in this case it
would be like uh 3 *
16 and now uh we're talking about
continuous random variables so as
opposed to discrete random
variables um these continuous random
variables can take any real value really
and they will Define a probability
density function or PDF
and we have an important difference here
which is that
um we're now looking at the area below
the curve um and the curve is Def is
definition
of using this notation that P of s p of
x equals uh small X which is like a
single value and in this case of a PDF
this probability would be zero because
in the PDF we're not talking about
intervals the probability of X belonging
to an interval let's say between a and
b um and one consequence of this new
definition that we have now is that uh
like one simple way that will uh replace
the definition we had before is that
we're going to replace the sums by
Integrations
so the properties are kind of the same
uh the probabilities of X belonging to
an interval given that this interval is
in the domain of X should be always
greater than zero and the area under the
PDF should be
one now I'm going to give just like an
example example of a very popular kind
of PDF which is the normal distribution
or the
G um so for one variable which is what
we're talking about so far and the PDF
of the gon is going to be given by this
expression over
here and it is um represented in figure
B so basically this is a standardized
gin which means that it has mean zero
and variance one so you can see that
most of the bass is at zero and the
variance of this G is
one um but you can also have more than
one variable so for example in C we have
two GES so this
axis is one gin and this other AIS is
another gausin and it has basically the
same shape but but in 2D is given by
this
expression um and you can kind of even
like visually see that the area under
the curve
is or in this case it's the
volume and in a we simply have like the
samples that we would get from this uh
to the G in
C uh basically when you have like a
probability distribution like this you
can also if it's in closed form if like
a typical distribution like the Gin you
can uh sample from easily which means
you can get those um we can can get
those samples and they're centered
around zero and they have like similar
shape but I believe there will be like a
tutorial sampling
later and here's an example of a PB pmf
it's the ber distribution which is the
example I've been using to motivate this
lecture since the beginning it's
basically a coin toss where theet is the
probability
uh of getting a hand for example and the
observations you can get from your coin
toss can be heads or tails so you have
two discrete values zero or
one and the way this is typically
written is like P of s given Theta and
it's going to be equal to the
probability uh of the data given the
parameter or it can also be written
Shand loation like this
which means basically that X is drawn
from a ber distribution with parameter
Thea and then in this case the pmf is
given by this expression uh we can read
it like slowly so for example P of X
being zero which is p of X being head
given um theeta being let's say
0.5 if we have an unbiased coin is
theeta to uh 0 * 1 - 0.5 to the power of
u 1 minus 0 which is
one so this is like a simple simple
expression that can can count for both
cases of X being zero or
one and here's a simple visualization of
uh this pmf given different values of
theeta basically like in dark red you
have uh theeta being
0.2 in dark blue you have theeta being
0.8 in in dark green you have theeta
being
0.5 um and basically these two
realizations are going to sum up to one
or their probabilities will sum up to
one uh I need my water
bot
and now you have um well I just
informally showed you like that you can
have more than one random variable and
so we can define a random Vector X which
is basically the concatenation of all
the random variables from X1 to
XD and then the joint probability of all
of these uh random
variables um is going to be written like
this like P of big x equals x where X is
all the
realizations X1 to
XD it is um an end kind of operation now
it's a probability of getting X1 and X2
and up to XD and it can also be written
like
this so I'm going to show you later how
it looks uh but now let's talk about the
marginal uh because there is a
difference between The Joint probability
and the marginal probability here
imagine a a case where you have two
variables X1 and X2 the the marginal of
X1 is the probability of X1 which is
basically the joint summed over all the
values of X2 and here I'm writing this
for uh with like discrete variable
notation but it's basically kind of the
same idea for continuous variable
so here's the example um here we have in
a samples of the joint X1 and
X2 um so the joint is really like this
function of of two variables and in B
basically it's a function of only one
variable uh here it's the marginal over
I think uh X2 so basically what we're
doing is like we're folding a and and it
has a shape like this which um we can
see between minus 1.5 and minus one the
probability will be zero and then beyond
that uh it will always increase because
you're increasing the amount of points
here this is um The Continuous
case so in general we can write it like
this
um well it's the same thing but just
like for multiple variables you have a
sum uh the marginal of X1 is basically a
sum over the variables
that all the values that all the other
variables can
take and then in the continuous case
it's the same thing but you have
integrals instead and notice that this
is going to be very computationally
expensive in a high dimensional case
because you have to compute all these
integrals and now uh let's talk about
conditional
probability conditional probability is
the probability of for example X1 given
X2 and it's given by this expression
it's
um The Joint of X1 and X2 divided by the
margin of X2 that I just defined
uh so we can go through this in detail
here I have all the realizations of X1
and x2 in the discrete case and here I
put explicitly the marginal of X2 being
uh the sum of the joints over X1 over
all the values that X1 can
take
and but I'm going to show you actually
how does it look like in the continuous
case here's the same joint the same
samples of the joint as we had
before
um and the conditional here is like
slicing basically uh or like you're
fixing the value of one of the variables
and you're looking at the distribution
of the other
variable uh so basically in C you have
the conditional of X2 given X1 equals
zero so if you look here in a we we go
to X1 equal zero and uh we slice it over
here and we look at this segment and the
distribution of X2 on this segment can
look we can see looks like pretty
homogeneous like
uniform uh so between minus 1.5 and
minus one there's like zero probability
and then between uh minus one and + one
we have this uniform probability which
seems to be
0.5 um and beyond that it's zero again
then again uh for in D we have the same
thing but a difference lies just to be
very clear uh here we have the the
condition of X1 given X2 being 0.5
0.75 so it's basically slicing it here
is this small segment and we're looking
at X1 it's zero for
X1 less than minus
0.45 and greater than
0.45 and otherwise it's like uniform in
this inside this area this
segment uh so here's the general case uh
for multiple variables
basically uh you
have the probability of one variable
given all the others it's equal to the
probability of all the variables divided
by um the probability of all the
ERS
and here uh basically the probability of
all the ERS is this marginalization over
the variable X1 that you're
considering uh
okay
so you can use the conditional
probability in the base rule which is
basically a way to invert the
conditional let's say uh you have um you
want to know X1 given X2 but you have
access to only X2 given
X1 uh you you want to get one as a
function of the other so from the
definition of conditional before I think
by the way uh people may not always
present present the base terem like this
but this is how I always remember it
like you need to rederive it otherwise
I'll mess it up so let's go and Define
the conditional um of X1 given X2 and X2
given X1 so here is just a definition I
put
before but now for one of them we can
rewrite it like this basically I just um
put the P of X1 to the left side and now
we have the probability of the joint P
of X1 and X2 and we can replace this
right here in the previous definition of
X1 given
X2 uh so here's the same definition but
now H but now with this instead and
that's it now we had the probability of
X1 given X2 as a function probability of
X2 given
X1 um over the marginal of
X2 this is the base rule um now one
example or like maybe like a more clear
way to write this in the discrete case
again would be let's say like you're
doing
classification and maybe um X1 is a
class cat or a dog and X2 is a feature
could be the nose size um sorry yeah
could be the nose length for example
some measurement you have and now you
want to know the probability of your
thing being a dog given uh the length
this feature and you have it as a uh the
probability of X2 being the length given
uh the class dog and the probability of
having dogs in your data and then here
in the denominator I wrote I rewrote the
marginal as a kind of a conditional so
basically this is the probability of X2
given X1 times the probability of X1
sumed over all the values of X1 which is
all the classes so cats or
dogs uh yeah so this is how it's kind of
used naive base for
example and well this is the general uh
definition of the base here
uh for multiple variables you can always
write uh P of X1 given all the other
variables as a function of all the other
variables given X1 and in the continuous
case uh the denominator will be uh an
integral
uh okay so going back to the conditional
probability we can apply it
successively uh to the Joint so you have
the probability of X1 X2 of 2xd and then
you can write it as the probability of
X2 up to XD times the probability of
X1 uh and then you can do it again for
this probability of X2 up to XD will now
be the probability of x3 up to XD times
X2 and then you had the probability of
X1 from before and you can apply this
recursively and basically obtain this
factorization which can be useful just
mentioning
it uh yeah and now independence is the
property of the random variables
basically if X1 and X2 are statistically
independent it means that any
information you can have on x2 X1 will
not uh inform you about the value of X2
and vice versa one to write this is that
the probability of X1 given X2 equals
the probability of X1 and the other way
around but in general let's say you can
see that X1 up to XD are mutually
independent that is X1 is independent of
X2 X3 of 2xd in all the
variables um then you can write it like
this then the joint factorizes as the
product of the marginals
and this is very useful and we're going
to use it
later um okay
now I'm going to talk about maximum
likelihood estimation which is switching
a bit more towards
statistics so a statistical model
describes the PDF or pmf of your
observed uh random samples or random uh
variables using uh
parameters and the side up is that you
have access to your observations you
have like n of them and your sample
sample set has size
n and these observations are independent
and they dally distributed it means that
let's say in the coin toss example uh
every time you toss a
coin
uh well you're tossing them
independently right each result you're
going to get head or fail it's
independent of the other and then uh
since you're tossing always the same
coin the same time and it has the same
probability of getting heads or tail
uh your distribution is also your
samples are always coming from this
identical distribution it's always the
same because your parameter is the
same um and the
goal for ML is given all these
observations you want to estimate the
parameters or theeta in this
case
um so we can write the likelihood that
the data was generated by the parameters
of your
model
we'll go through this slowly uh first
the probability of the data is the
probability of the joint X1 up to xn of
your
observations but it's conditioned on the
parameters and since uh each of these
observations are independent of each
other uh we can use the independence
property that we just showed before to
factorize the this into the product of
uh the conditionals of each x i given
theeta um and this is called the
likelihood and then maximum likelihood
estimation we want to maximize the
likelihood that the data was generated
by the parameters so basically you're
maximizing this over Theta which is the
perimeter you want to estimate and the
uh maximum value would be your
estimation however um in machine
learning and computational
statistics um usually logarithms of
probabilities are like more
computationally stable and more useful
so we can instead
and take the log likelihood which is the
long of the likelihood and that here in
second line remember that uh the log of
the joint
probabilities is the sum of the logs so
the log likelihood can be expressed by
this and since the logarithmic function
is monotonically
increasing H if you maximize the log of
the function you'll be maximizing the
function so then basically your
estimated Theta will be the ARX of the
log likelihood over
Theta um okay uh and here's the Basin
approach to
um like the mle what I which I just
presented is basically the frequentist
approach to to to parameter
estimation and the Basin approach uh is
a bit different because it treats the
uncertainty as random variable so
whenever you have uncertainty you kind
of like put a belief on it which means
you put a prior on it and then you apply
the base
theorem um so here's um how it's defined
this is basically the base theorem that
for param your variables are now the
parameters in the
observations so I have the probability
of the parameters given your data being
the probability of the data given your
parameters probability of the parameters
which is the prior divided by the
marginal uh P of
x uh here uh P of theta given X is
called the posterior
belief
um and it is usually what is kind of
either maximized
or what you want to get because
intuitively makes sense if you want to
like optimize directly for Theta and not
for x given Theta and then maximizing
over theeta um here P of x given Theta
this term here is the likelihood
basically like we had before so it's the
observation model and P of theta is the
prior
belief
[Music]
um
which uh can be conditioned on hyper
priors let's say if you have like some
kind of belief on various degrees of
uncertainty you can uh keep growing this
with more priors um and then p ofx is
the normalization or marinal
likelihood um so I would basically
mention like two ways of doing this one
is the Basin way okay uh sorry one is
the posterior means which means that
your estimate is uh the expectation of
um your posterior basically like your
expectation of theta given
X and the other approach that I
personally consider the Basin approach
maybe it's not pure Basin but it's
maximum posteriority or map and
basically here it's like I said you're
optimize
um basically here's the
log of the
posterior kind of and they're maximizing
this uh over
theeta and well I thought I wouldn't
have more time I see there's there's
still a few minutes but I can stop right
here and if you have any questions I
also wanted to mention the these slides
have been inspired I forgot to mention
before H it was nicely inspired by no
lecture notes by Simone Pascal and Apple
so a lot of the pictures you have here
have been taken from them and that's it
thank you I hope it's kind of
helpful yeah
oh sorry I for than VI yeah yeah yeah um
so here
the I had mentioned there's like you can
have a hyper prior which is a prior oner
prior so basically you can have theeta
given uh Alpha and so you can have like
but I think in the case of like um coin
tosses they put like beta distributions
gamma and then like prior of gamma over
beta and so on and you can put a lot of
priors
yes I didn't get what the difference is
between your prior and Hyper
prior yeah sorry I think I should have
given like a complete example of this
but I thought it would run out of time
but a hyper prior is a prior you put on
your prior so let's say if your
probability of
of here let's say probability of theeta
has should be between zero and one right
uh but you can put a
prior on uh oh my God how can
we you can put a prior on on this
prior
like let's say you have now the joint of
uh P of
um pet being uh well is not the best
example okay can you help me
like
so so yeah so prior you can think about
it as um being some a prior knowledge
that you that you have about the system
that you want to model so you you can
specify it if you have if you have
expert knowledge for example you can
specify the prior but what if you don't
really know how to specify this prior
knowledge in the first place so you
could say okay I I'm I don't know I have
some uncertainty still about this this
prior itself so I can put a hyper prior
on top of it to say okay I'm I'm making
P even fewer assumptions about the
system that I'm making so as as you go
up you're making fewer and fewer
assumptions is there any other questions
for
Victoria all right let's let's thank
Victoria
again so now we we have H we have a
little break uh and so we have uh some
uh some coffee and P Tre is there uh and
we'll uh start again at
for
well
right
hello everyone let's come back from the
break and listen to another
tutorial please take your
seat okay great thank you uh okay so H
the next talk is going to be by tristano
he's the final year PhD student with
yosha and he's going to talk about
probabilistic modeling the floor is
yours thanks
Sasha uh so hi everyone uh it's me again
I'm uh going to talk about probabilistic
modeling uh so it will be a followup uh
from we we're going to follow up from
Victoria's presentation uh going from
what our probabilities what were
conditional probabilities base Rule and
everything like that and how do we use
these things like what what is this
actually used for in
practice um okay
so maybe one of the first question is uh
that that you may ask is why do we may
we want to use probabilistic models
because like nowadays we we see uh so
many great applications of machine
learning in AI uh and uh we have so so
many powerful models that are doing
great predictions uh all the way uh and
so you may ask like why do we want to
put probabilities on top of it why do we
want to to do any of that so I'm trying
to to give you a few um a few reasons
why this might be helpful to to think
about probabilities uh in particular
when it comes to modeling uh with
machine learning um and so the the main
thing is that when you get a powerful
predictive model so let think let's
think about like a powerful nowadays
like Transformer let's say uh there is
so a predictive model they're not really
designed to uh represent the uncertainty
that you have about the predictions that
they're making so they're just making
predictions they're just making
decisions but they don't tell you how
confident they are and so this can be
very risky because sometimes these
models they can make very wrong
predictions with very high confidence
they might be uh very sure about like
something that is going to happen but uh
without telling you okay I'm not really
sure uh if uh if the the outcome is
going to to be what I'm predicting so
one of the examples of this risky
situations might be in self-driving cars
and we see uh still within the past few
weeks some news about it where you may
not want your uh car to just make
decisions without uh really thinking
about it you want to also your model to
be uh to give you some kind of um
knowledge about how uncertain it is
about the situation that it's facing
currently um and so these models uh
these uh prediction models they are they
can also be prone to be fooled by
address or examples so you might have
seen some of these examples where you
have some image that you can you you see
uh that is visually very close to let's
say something that looks like uh
a a car uh but actually uh is is just
adding adding a little bit of noise to
your to your um uh to uh to the to the
image that you're you're uh trying to
predict in order to for the model to
actually make the wrong predictions and
so it's not going to to to be a car but
it's actually going to be like just a
free Road and so maybe your your car is
just going to detect that there is
nothing like there's nothing in front of
it and crash into the the car in front
of it so these uh predictions they it
may lead to to harmful predictions uh
harmful just like on the standard things
uh standard meaning of the world of the
word but also uh from a fairness
perspective because maybe some of these
uh some of these models are going to
make wrong predictions about parts of
the population which may not be uh well
represented into these data sets and so
if we had models that could also uh tell
us how uncertain we are about the
predictions that we're making maybe
these kinds of situations may appear
less often and finally uh these very
powerful predictive models they are uh
often
lacking interpretability and so one of
the nice things about these
probabilistic models that like some of
them that I'm going to talk about um
today uh it's that they are really good
for uh for making interpretable
predictions uh and so this you may you
may think that we don't really care
about interpretability uh at the end of
the day we just want to make good
predictions uh but in some applications
this might be exactly what you're
looking for and so for example when when
it comes to scientific discovery what
matters is not really what what is the
prediction that you're making down the
line it's trying to get an understanding
about the world uh that you're trying to
model so all these things uh I'm not
saying that probabalistic models gives
you all that for free but this is kind
of the direction in which we want to go
uh when we talk about probabilistic
models so I want to go back to one of
the examples that Victoria talked about
earlier uh which is really the simp simp
kind of probabilistic model that you can
think of which is this model of uh which
is
modeling tossing a biased coin um so
let's say you want to you want to model
the outcome of flipping a coin and this
coin might be biased so it's not the
regular coin that you would have where
you have 5050 chance of uh eating heads
or or tails uh this coin might give you
more often heads than than tails and so
the way you can
model this thing is to say okay I have a
probability of having my coin landing on
on heads which has probability p and
then I have a probability of the coin uh
landing on Tails which has probability
one minus P because we saw earlier that
these probabilities they have to be
normalized so the the sum of the
probabilities over the different
outcomes here there's just two outcomes
it has to sum to one so that's why we
have p and one minus p and so as
Victoria presented earlier um this model
is what we call a bernui distribution so
it's a bernui model and we write it with
some parameters p and we write it in
this way so we has we have x with this
Squigly uh line uh with bernly p and
this just means that the outcome X so
this random variable X that we have is
distributed according to the bernly
distribution
and so what can we do with this model
well so far I haven't seen anything and
we we've seen earlier like uh what we
what we can do with this uh but um as a
as a general rule of thumb when you have
a probabilistic model uh you can
generate some data you can sample from
it so this is sometimes what we call
generative
generative models so you may have heard
this whole re revolution of generative
AI this is uh really one of the simplest
examples of what you would have as a
generative model and you can generate
data so if you have let's say your your
random variable which is distributed
according to a beri with 05 probability
of landing on heads or tails then you
can generate data so you can uh simulate
these uh this flipping of coins uh as
much as you want uh to get as much data
as you want and we'll see later uh why
we want we would like to to do this
thing and uh throughout this Workshop
why this would be a good a good thing to
be able to sample things from a from a a
probabilistic
model so this burnly model uh we saw
that it has some parameters p uh but
what if we don't know what's the what's
the parameter p and so we we saw earlier
that uh this is this um these two
directions between having a
probabilistic model and doing statistics
so here if we have access to a data set
set of observations we may want to find
what's the what are the parameters that
could explain this data set that we are
observing and so this is what what is
all about statistics um so let's say we
have a data set of 10 observations four
of them are heads and six of them are
tails and one way that we saw how to uh
how to find the the parameters that
could explain this uh these observations
is through maximum likelihood estimation
so ma maximum likelihood estimation
Victoria presented the general frame the
general uh the general way of of
thinking about mle uh but really uh the
underlying principle is that what is the
part what what is the parameter that
best explains the observations that
we're seeing so this is very intuitive
when we see this this very this very
simple model here uh the uh the
parameter is just the number of uh times
we we have heads in our data set over
the size of the overall size of the data
set that we have so here it would be uh
4 over
10 so we saw uh that this this coin was
slightly biased because we we saw that
it was not quite 0.5 it was 0.4 the the
probability of of landing on on heads um
but now what would happen if we see
situation where all of the observations
that we're seeing are just tailes so
does that mean that the um the uh we are
never going to see heads because if we
uh if we were to use the maximum
likelihood principle that we we saw
earlier it would mean that the parameter
that best explains this data is actually
zero so we have zero probability of of
seeing heads which is well it's fairly
un it's fairly unnatural maybe we were
just unlucky in the data that we were
seeing even though it was uh identically
distributed uh but it's this this is the
the kind of situation that could happen
um and so another like another way of
seeing that is to take a beijan
perspective so instead of really trying
to find what's the single parameter that
can best explain the data that we're
observing we could say okay I have some
prior knowledge about uh about the world
so we could say maybe there is an equal
probability that my parameter is going
to be either zero 0.1 0.2 up to one so
this could be a uniform uh distribution
over all the possible values that these
uh these parameters P could take so this
is the the graph that we see on the on
the top and then the bean perspective
tells us how to change this belief that
we have about the world so we start with
having no prior knowledge whatsoever we
have equal chance of having of having
all the models that could explain the
data and then once we observe some data
we update this belief uh so we go to
this posterior distribution and this is
just another distribution that will tell
us how likely uh we uh we are to uh that
these parameters are actually explaining
the data uh if we observe this uh this
amount of data so this changes from what
we we saw earlier because if we observe
no heads and 10 Tails then the
distribution that we will get at the for
the posterior distribution is of course
going to be concentrated around zero
it's not going to be just zero we have
still some chance to uh to to have the
probability P to be very very small and
so we still leave the chance for the
model to um to uh to model these kinds
of of situation sitations where uh maybe
we were just unlucky in the data that
we're seeing and this is very important
especially if the the amount of data
that you're seeing is very small because
maybe you don't you don't see all of the
possible outcomes that could happen in
uh in in your uh for your random
variable so here we're really taking
that into account from the ban
perspective but we're not really losing
anything when we're looking at the bean
perspective because if we take the
example that we saw earlier if we have
four heads and six tails we saw that the
maximum likelihood estimate was 0.4 and
then if we taking this Bean perspective
we see that the posterior distribution
is going to be somewhat concentrated
around 0.4 but it's still leaves the
chance for some other values of the
parameters to also exist so this is
really related to to this concept of
regularization in machine learning if
you're more familiar with that uh and
the maximum likelihood estim
tends to somewhat overfit to the data uh
to the data that you're seeing so here
we're leaving the chance of different
other models to also
exist um so I'm going to go quickly over
that because vioria also talked about
this but we have some very basic uh
probabilistic models that exist that can
model different kinds of data uh so I'm
just highlighting some of the very basic
building blocks that we can uh that we
can uh play with
so we saw the normal distribution
earlier we can also have some uniform
distribution over continuous variables
the beri model which is the one uh for
the coin toss that we we saw earlier we
can generalize that to cases where we
have multiple outcomes multiple values
that the random variable can take which
is a categorical distribution and then
you have also this Pon distribution
which is what you would use for example
if you want to model uh you want to
model some counts so in some biological
applications you have some counts of uh
things that you you are going to observe
and so this is the natural distribution
that you can use for that so these are
really uh really you can think about
them as being building blocks and we can
use them combine them together in order
to build something which is a little bit
more uh more complex so how do we do it
how do we uh how do we have something
which is uh how can we model something
uh which is going to be more complex so
if we have a complex system we what we
want is not just to uh to model uh the
distribution over a single variable but
we want to model a whole joint
distribution so we saw earlier what is a
joint distribution this is the
probability of X1 and X2 and X3 and so
on um and so we we have different parts
that we want to to define the
distribution order so here I have an
example where I want to define a
distribution over for example the season
uh whether we have a flu we have the flu
or not whether we have hay fever or not
whether we we have muscle pain and whe
whe whether we have congestion and so we
have some natural connections between
these different random variables which I
showed uh here and we can use we can
leverage these uh these natural
Connections in order to build our
probabilistic model and so the one of
the reasons why we may want to do that
is because it might be very challenging
to define a joint distribution in
general because if you think about it
this joint distribution between X1 to XD
I need to Define what's the value of the
probability for each possible outcomes
that these all of these variables
jointly can take and so if you have
let's say X1 can that can take two two
values X2 that can take two values and
so on all of these variables are binary
what you end up with is having to
specify y uh an exponential number of
different values because you have all of
the possible outcomes all of these
different variables can take so this is
very expensive because it like your your
system you can have many many different
parts that can that are is making your
system uh you can have multip each of
these pieces can take multiple values so
it's really going to be very very
expensive very quickly um so one of
these ideas uh uh which is behind uh
something which is called ban networks
and this is one of the illustration that
we have here is instead of uh defining
the probability of each of these
possible um each of these possible
outcomes individually we can modularize
uh The Joint probability distribution in
such a way that each small each piece
can be can be uh
modeled as a probabilistic model and
then we we just have to specify the
model for each of this individual piece
and then we combine them together in
order to find to to get a overall
probabilistic model which is powerful
for the whole system so in this example
instead of having the joint distribution
between all of these different variables
we can say it's the we we can uh we can
decompose that into the probability of
the Season times the probability of flu
given the season and so on and so forth
so maybe it's very easy to to specify
what's the probability what's a
probability distribution of having the
flu given the season because it's more
likely to have the flu uh during winter
for example than it is during uh during
the summer and the opposite for hay
fever it's more likely to to have hay
fever during spring and and summer than
it is dur during the other season so
each of these pieces might be easy to
model uh and then we combine all of them
together to to get something which is
more uh
more uh more
complex um so so what can you do with a
probabilistic model so I I told you I
motivated why you may want to to do to
to get a probabalistic model compared to
your standard prediction model that
people have been developing in machine
learning um but why would you want to to
to have a probabilistic model concretely
what do you want to to do with that so
we saw earlier that we can use that for
sampling or for generating data uh so if
you have the this uh this probabilistic
model we can just sample some data
uh to to look like what to some uh some
fake outcomes of this uh of this
probabilistic model we saw also that we
can learn the parameters from data so if
we're given a data a data set of
observations how can we find the
parameters for this uh for this
probabilistic model we can also use
it and this is where it becomes very
interesting we can still we can also use
it to answer questions so uh we we can
answer questions for example for example
what is the probability that I will be
late at work uh I will be late for work
given that it is riging so this sounds a
lot like what you would have what you
would uh write down as a conditional
distribution that we we saw with
Victoria and so this is precisely why
having a probabalistic model might might
be helpful like this is the kind of
questions that we can we can answer with
that and this is a whole whole field of
what we call probabilistic inference so
if you hear probabilistic inference it
means answering questions and so we'll
have uh we'll have a session right after
presented by Sebastian uh where we we
will see how to use these probabilistic
models in order to do to answer these
kinds of questions and then finally
we're not losing anything we can still
do predictions with these probabilistic
models we just uh we we're just adding
some new features on top of it uh and
still still get these these predictions
predictions Pro capabilities of of these
Models All right so I want to talk about
like a a very simple example of a of a
probabilistic model which is very uh
crucial in the whole literature on
probabilistic models and we'll also use
that uh uh in the coming days some of
these Notions to uh when it comes to uh
G flets so and this model is is called
The Mark of chain so let's say you want
to you you want to model a sequence of
objects so when it comes to sequences
usually what people use is just language
models uh but I'm taking another example
which is actually RNA sequences instead
so RNA sequences you have uh just a
sequence of
characters and each of these characters
can take one of four different values so
either a c g or U and uh if we want to
specify a distribution like a
probability distribution over sequences
we need to specify a joint distribution
over all of the the the joint
distribution over all the characters
that are uh making this sequence and so
we saw in in the the presentation
earlier that this joint distribution in
as a general fact we can use the uh the
chain rule to the to decompose that as P
of X1 * P of X2 given X1 and adding to
the conditioning along the way uh to end
up with something which is p of XT given
everything else that we've seen uh we've
seen in the past and so if we think
about uh how many how many parameters
how many uh how many values of the
probabilities we need to specify for
this model where we we're still in the
same problem as as we saw earlier
earlier like we were since we this de
composition is very general uh we still
have to uh to specify an exponential
number of uh values for the
probabilities of each possible outcomes
uh for for this uh for this General
model so this model is uh what we call a
notor regressive model because we're
generating things one at a
time um and so we we still need to uh
specify this conditional distribution
over XT given everything everything that
came before and this has to be uh to be
specified for all the possible choices
of the past so we we have to take into
account all of the history before we are
trying to predict what's the final car
of our sequence so this will be
expensive uh and so an alternative way
of uh an alternative way of modeling
this kind of problems is to model that
as a mark of change so instead of
specifying these all of these very
complex uh conditional distributions
that are growing over time and we have
to specify a lot of different
probabilities for each of them uh what
we're going to do is make the assumption
that if we want to what the predictions
that we want to make the probability of
the next character does not depend on
the whole history before it but it only
depends on what we see currently so what
it means in terms of the joint
distribution it means that when we want
to model P of X1 to XT The Joint
distribution this is p of X1 time P of
X2 given X1 time P of x3 given only X2
and so on so each of the conditioning
only depends on the on the previous uh
on the previous character so of course
we're making we're making a strong
assumption here we're saying that each
character only depends on the previous
one so we're losing uh a little bit in
terms of expressivity and it makes sense
because in terms of the uh the the
number of parameters that we that we
have for this model will have much fewer
parameters when it comes to mark of
chain compared to the general case with
an autor regressive model but it's still
very convenient in many applications to
to look at these Mark of chains and it's
especially we we'll see uh that it plays
an important role when it comes to gonet
uh tomorrow and the day
after um another class of models that I
want to highlight uh which might be also
very interesting in many applications is
the class of model which which are
energy based models so what we saw so
far is that each of these all of these
uh probability probabilistic models that
we saw they have to be normalized so we
need to use building blocks that are
made of uh distributions that are
properly normalized and so maybe this is
very limiting because uh if we we are
modeling something which is very complex
like let's say uh how to how to generate
an image for example when we when it
comes to the generative AI uh if we want
to to specify what's the distribution
for over uh the space of images well it
doesn't really look like the beri
distribution that we saw earlier or even
the normal distribution that we saw so
it's it's like it's much more complex
than that and so another way to specify
to to have more
flexibility uh in our definition of the
of a probabilistic model is to Define it
using uh an energy function so we're
going to specify the probabilistic model
only up to a normalization constant Zed
and we'll just uh specify this energy
and this energy you can think about it
as uh measuring how compatible different
things are together so I'm I'm showing a
few examples on the on the right hand
side so let's say we have have an object
recognition um application and but we
don't necessar we don't necessarily know
how to model exactly uh going from the
image to the probability over the labels
of this image naturally but what you can
do is to feed all of these in these two
the these two components into an energy
function that tells us how compatible
these two objects are going to be
together so let's say for example if we
have an image of a cat and the label cat
together then they're going to be more
likely to to to go together compared to
if it was with the with an image of a
dog so with the label of a dog sorry so
this is this is really a very flexible
way of of specifying specifying nor
probalistic
models uh but the really
the challenge here now is that we still
have this normalization constant this
Zed uh which corresponds to uh summing
over all the possible outcomes that we
have for uh for the variable the random
variable X can take and this thing can
be very very hard to compute like in
general you you you cannot enumerate all
the possible opt all the possible
outcomes that X can take for the same
reasons that what we we saw earlier like
there might be an exponential number of
of these of these outcomes so this this
normalization uh con is in general
intractable and this might be a very
this makes things uh very difficult uh
to do so like some of these um features
that that I presented earlier when it
comes to having a probabalistic model so
just sampling learning from data and
stuff like that becomes more challenging
when it comes to uh an energy based
model because we don't have an explicit
access to uh this normalization constant
that so this this is where where things
can be get a little bit tricky but
luckily we'll see we'll see some uh some
applications of gonet where we can
actually use gonet to answer some of
these so to address some of these
challenges and so I want to go back to
like as an application not direct
application of energy based models but
uh taking inspiration from what we we
just saw uh so if you remember when we
talked about B the vasion perspective
when we talked about posteriors uh that
posterior distributions that were
encoding some belief that we have about
the uh the model uh the model which is
describing the system uh this is also
defined as a probability distribution up
to a normalization constant it's really
the same thing we have P of D given P
which is the likelihood if you remember
from Victoria's presentation times P of
P which is the prior and then we divide
by by something which is the
normalization constant and the same way
that we saw that in energy based models
this constant Zed was very challenging
to compute and it's intractable to
compute in general when it comes to ban
basian posteriors this evidence this P
of D the normalization constant is also
going to be intractable in like in many
uh in many cases and so we we still are
in the same situation as what we uh that
what we saw for energy based models and
so gonets what the the whole purpose of
this this whole workshop and what we'll
s we'll see uh in the coming days is
that gonet there are going to be a class
of probabilistic models where you can
specify the model up to a normalization
constant and you can still use uh you
can still answer all of these questions
that we uh we saw earlier so learning
from data sampling using the gonets uh
but we'll see we'll see that uh we'll
see that uh at least
tomorrow I just want to finish uh the
presentation just to say that okay I
gave you a very basic introduction to
probabilistic models but it's not just
about like these very very basic models
uh nowadays we we have H we have
probabalistic models that are doing
amazing thing that can generate a really
like really high dimensional very
structured very complex uh data uh and
so this uh this is something that we we
still uh need to acknowledge uh so for
example uh we have Gans that were re
that were all the craze these past few
years up until let's say 2020 uh and
then more recently we have also this
class of models called diffusion models
and so these two things if you've heard
of these these models and probably
diffusion models lately which have
become more powerful uh these are also
examples of probabilistic models because
we're generating some data we're
sampling data and so we can still uh we
can still interpret them as
probabilistic models and so this uh this
is just to to to say that there are some
really real world applications of these
probabilistic models not just the uh
coin toss that I I explained uh in at
the
beginning all right so that's it I want
Tok thank you for for attending I'm just
showing a few a few good resources if
you want to go a little bit further when
it comes to uh probabalistic modeling uh
in particular the probabalistic machine
learning book which is very good a very
recent uh resource which is covering a
lot of these uh very well-known
wellestablished probabilistic models but
also these new probabilistic models that
I briefly touched upon lately and then
so some of these other books which are
more uh more ref like better also good
references when it comes to classical uh
probabilistic machine learning that's it
thank
you maybe we have
a maybe we have time for couple of
questions we have any questions in the
audience yes could you go to the mic
please uh when uh when determining like
the uh the result of of an energy based
model how exactly you said it's a it's a
level of similarity I guess that you go
and get is it from zero to one or is
it's an energy base it's
can be anything exactly so the energy
can be really anything uh so that's
that's really the beauty of specifying
your your distribution up to
normalization constant is that these
values of the energy can be really
anything and then you will get a
probability distribution by normalizing
it U Down the Line so the only the only
constraint that you have when it comes
to probabilities is that they have to be
positive as well so we need to we need
to make sure that these ities will be
positive but this is this is guaranteed
by taking the exponential of your energy
so this uh but the energy itself can be
really anything and in various
applications we we have the energy can
be uh really positive negative anything
like that so that would leave me to my
next question which is uh in that case
when you're building a data set for that
how do you determine arbitrarily the
energy of two different elements so
there are there are different ways of
specifying the the energy maybe you have
some uh physical like physic physical
model that can give you what's the
what's the energy of a of a particular
example so for example uh I'm not I'm
not an expert but I think when it comes
to drug Discovery we can have some
binding energy for example that that we
have some models that can give give that
to us and so we can use directly this
Oracle uh for the energy to uh to
directly uh get the energy and then you
have the other approach which is that we
can also learn the energy so the same
way that we we saw earlier that we could
have a probabilistic model where we know
the parameters and then we can use them
we can also go the other way around the
statistics way where where we we have
the uh probabilistic model we have a
data set and then we can learn the
parameters of this pro probabilistic
model which here would mean learning the
parameters of the energy function
and so you have plenty of methods of of
learning this energy function um you can
use gradient based methods so this was
really popular um I I want to say like
in the mid 2000s when when uh with some
things like uh boltzman machines so the
predecessor of this deep learning cze um
so this when if you've heard of bolman
machines this was really this was really
uh an energy based model down the line
so you can still use gradient methods to
uh to train these things from data thank
you very much thank
you okay let's thank Tristan
again and yeah let introduce our next
speaker thank you uh so our next speaker
is uh Sebastian rap uh Sebastian is a
research scientist as at Samsung sale uh
lab he's uh working uh broadly on causal
representation learning uh and uh today
he's going to talk about he's also a PhD
student at at Mila uh and today he's
going to talk about uh probabilistic
inference so please welcome
semester
right thank you hello everyone uh my
name is Sebastian Chappelle yeah I'm a
PhD student here at Mila and also a
research stist at Samsung just over here
uh so today I've been asked to talk
about probalistic inference so that's
what I'm going to do let me just set the
timer there we go
um so
uh yeah yeah so we're going to see uh
what what is probabilistic inference
together uh I'm going to give some
examples of tractable inference
problems uh so we're going to see The
Mark of chain an example that Tristan
covered before going to see the Gan
mixture and also factor
analysis uh then we're going to try to
make these examples a little bit more
interesting uh but by doing that we're
going to make the uh inference Pro
problem Interactive
so uh we're going to see
that uh and then we're going to see like
two broad categories of approaches to
deal with these so-called intractable
inference problems so we're going to see
sampling based inference so today so in
this lecture I'm just going to give like
a high level view of what that is I
think that that's the topic for the next
lecture and then I'm going to talk about
variational inference and I will sort of
build up to towards variational encoders
which some of you might know but maybe
not from that exact
perspective um so let me jump
in so what is protic
inference um so protic inference is simp
is simply the the computational problem
of uh Computing different queries about
given probabilistic model okay so you
might let me just find my uh laser
pointer go so you might have your
probalistic model for uh and random
variables and uh you know protic
inference is simply the problem of
computing various quantities like
marginal distributions or conditional
distributions um and you know we we we
already saw these um these objects in
the previous lectures so let me just
explain this
this anation quickly so I'm going to say
that um X x s here is essentially uh the
sub Vector of of X made of the
coordinates in the subset so s is a
subset of indices and Xs is essentially
a sub Vector of s corresponding to these
to these
indices um and so that's the high level
idea you might also want to compute
various statistics about these um about
these objects like expectation
maximum AR Max all these things and so
we're going to see how we can tackle
this and of course yeah that's the
distinction between uh discrete and
continuous and yeah the sum here we have
to sum over all
the all the possible values that the
vector XS complement can take so here SC
stands for S
complement uh so that's the idea
so we're going to uh take an example so
this is the the discrete Mark of chain
so we have a chain of D random variables
these are discrete variables and they
can take a k different values and we're
going to make the assumption that this
distribution factorizes like this so
um uh so yeah exactly so essentially you
have the product of P of x times P of x
given X1 and so on and so forth up until
u p of x given P of XD given XD minus
one and the probabilistic query that
we're going to look into now is how to
compute a marginal distribution over XD
so the last variable in the
sequence and so just using the
definition of a marginal what we're
doing is
simp uh summing over all the other
variables so integrating over all the
other variables so what we have to do
here is we have to sum over all uh the
possible values of um all the variables
except D essentially we can rewrite this
sum as as such you have multiple sums
like
this and to go from this line to this
line uh what I'm doing is essentially
just pulling some terms out of these
sums okay so for instance here the term
px1 um you know it doesn't depend on XD
minus one here so I can I can sort of
pulling pull it out of the of the sum
okay and I can do that all the way up to
the the very last sum uh right because
X1 depends only on X1 so I can put it
out of all of these sums okay so it's
it's sort of like a
constant as a function of of X2 and uh
the later
variables and what I'm doing here is I'm
just doing the same thing for every term
so I can also pull P of X2 given X1 out
of all of these sums and I bring it
essentially here so I'm doing that U
sort of recursively and I get this this
expression uh of course these two
expressions are equal but interestingly
they have uh different um computation
cost so if you were to evaluate this sum
naively uh you would have to sum an
exponential number of ter so exponential
in the length of the sequence right
because you can count the number of
terms that you have in the sum and
essentially yeah you have uh you have to
sum over all the possibilities like yeah
over over all the possible values of X1
X2 up to XT minus one so it's an
exponential number of
terms uh so that's pretty costly oras if
you try to compute this sum you're going
to have a linear cost in the in in the
length of the sequence so essentially
what happens here is that here I'm I'm
summing over over only XD minus one so I
have K terms in this sum then you can
evaluate this sum uh you also have a
cost of K and you do that uh sort of
recursively like this and so you you you
you have to take the uh sums of K terms
so you have a cost of KD so essentially
the moral of the story here is that even
though um you know these things are sort
of easy to Define
mathematically um they uh like exactly
how you're going to compute uh those
those things will have uh you know like
a significantly significant impact on on
on the cost of of doing that and um so
so yeah that's the idea and this is by
the way um a special case of a more
General algorithm called variable
elimination and yeah there is like a
whole field of of about that essentially
variable elimination works for General
General factorization so here I'm just
talking about the chain but you can have
more complex uh graphical models as
Tristan explained before uh any
questions on on this or I should take
the questions at the end maybe or yeah
questions all
right
okay so yet another example of exact
inference would be doing inference in a
gaan mixture so uh what is a gan mixture
so you have a categorical variable Z
which you don't observe and uh for each
category you have a gan density so
essentially the
the the density of x given category
category Z is a gaan with a mean and a
covariance okay and of course the mean
and covariance can change for different
clusters and so when you look at the the
density over X that gives you this sort
of bumpy uh density function I'm not
going to discuss how to fit this
distribution to data I'm just going to
assume that you have this model and that
you want to do uh inference so here it's
a very very simple model so uh inference
happens to be easy right so we are in
the tractable or exact inference section
so what we want to do is you are given a
new data point x0 and you would like to
compute uh the probability that this
sample x0 belongs to uh the different
categories Z okay so essentially you
want to compute P of Z given
x0 uh so in that case you can just you
know apply uh I guess this is yeah the
definition of of uh of of the
conditional uh so you have the joint
here on in the numerator you have the
marginal in the denominator uh you can
sort of rewrite this
uh in this way and you get this
expression and it turns out that you
know all of these terms you can you know
they are given by by this model so you
can actually just go ahead and compute
compute this some and I will give you uh
the distribution of Z given x0 so this
is a a very simple example where um
doing inference on a nonobserved
variable Z is uh is is cheap or easy to
perform uh does that make sense still
yeah okay okay so I have a last example
of tractable inference so now we're
going to consider
a latent variable Z that is so by when I
say latent I mean I mean hidden in the
sense that you don't you don't observe
it um so now my latent variable will be
uh a continuous Vector instead of a
categorical variable we're going to
assume that it's a normal distribution
that is normally distributed uh with
means zero and covariance
identity and now P of x given Z is a
normal
distribution uh but the mean is
essentially a linear transform
of the latent Vector Z and the coari is
just the diagonal okay um okay so you
might want to learn a model like this
maybe to learn an interesting
representation about your
data um so again I'm not going going to
talk about how to exactly fit this model
to your data uh you could use the EM
algorithm uh to do it uh but so again
now I'm just going to discuss how to
actually uh compute the posterior
of Z given
x0 so again it's the same story as
before we have a data point x0 and we
want to compute to have a sense of like
what is the latent variable Z that has
given rise to this sample x0 so we want
the posterior P of Z given x0 and we're
not going to look into the computations
of how how to compute that but it turns
out that you can compute this um uh
exactly so there's a close form solution
to this problem and essentially it turns
out that P of Z x0 is still gussan and
the parameters of this Gan are given by
some function of the parameters W and uh
the covariances in in the diagonal
covariance here um so this is again an
example of a trackable inference problem
I'm not giving you the details it's just
to show you that in some cases inference
is easy can just uh compute it and of
course if you want to have the details
about what is exactly the parameters of
this uh of this post here you can look
at K Murphy's
book
um so okay questions about uh these
simple
examples
uh no Crystal Clear good um okay
so all of the examples that I gave are
tractable you can um compute the the
query that's you uh that you are
interested in uh exactly and
cheaply uh so now what I'm going to do
is I'm going to uh make the examples
that we look that we looked at a little
bit more interesting uh we want to have
like more expressive models but by but
by doing that what usually happens is
that inference becomes interact or much
more computationally
challenging uh so if we take the mark of
chain example and we sort of relax this
chain assumption and we just allow the
distribution to be essentially any
distribution um you get this uh this
factorization which is which applies to
any
distribution uh in that case if you try
to apply you know the trick that we saw
of like pulling terms out of the sums to
get a linear cost um you be able to do
it because of the because it's a it's
it's a General Distribution you will
always uh be stuck with this um
exponential cost in terms of um in terms
of the number of variables okay so this
is an example where
uh exact inferences is is possible but
it's just very costly for very long
sequences if you consider a model like
that um another example would be to
relax the the factor analysis model that
we saw before nothing relax but like
make the model more expressive okay we
will go from a simple linear model to a
deep generative model okay so we're
going to replace the linear function
that we have here by a a Neal Network
parameterized by uh some parameter Theta
okay so uh it's it's like the same model
but the this mapping here can be much
more general of course this is you know
much more expressive model you can
express much more interesting
distribution
with a model like this but again
you're there's an issue of like how do
you compute these the posterior okay so
before we had a an exact form for the
solution now we're stuck with this um
with this uh integral essentially here
that that appears in the denominator
which is
intractable um because if if you were
like to open up this this integral and
and write it down explicitly you would
have like this non linear function Here
app appearing and it wouldn't be clear
exactly how to how to compute this
integral um so there's no close firm
solution so there's always like this
dense of you you want to make your model
more expressive but each time you do
that you you you have like the the cost
of inference becomes larger or like
inference becomes more more difficult
okay so that's always sort of the the
trade-offs that uh that we are doing
when people are um developing these
these these methods
so uh okay we're going to see
essentially how to get around these
problems in some cases so we're going to
do approximate inference so approximate
inference uh generally refers to um you
know VAR a variety of of methods to to
go around these intractable inference
problems um and there are general
principles to do that uh and we're going
to see like two general principles to do
it but in general like exactly how
you're going to
tackle a problem is going to be very
dependent on the structure of the
problem you care about like so for
different problems you're going to use
different tools and uh the details of
how you you do things will change
depending on the model uh you deal with
okay but still you can sort of identify
like broad categories of of methods to
do approximate inference and so uh the
two important categories I'm going to
talk about today is sampling methods and
variational methods
um okay so for sampling methods uh so I
there's a there's a lecture after so I'm
just going to be I'm I'm going to be
very brief and and very um uh you know
succint so uh essentially in sampling
methods what what you do is you come up
with a an algorithm to sample from the
distribution you care about okay and
this is so this this is like um
um yeah it's like random sample
generation and and this is like a very
uh Rich field there's a lot of
literature on how to how to do that um I
won't give the details of how to do it
um but I guess the the lecture after me
will will give some of these details um
for instance you could use a G Net to to
sample from your distribution that would
be like one way to do it so I guess um J
are sort of part of of sampling methods
in a sense um and so here what I'm going
to do is I'm I'll just assume that you
have a way to sample to sample from uh
from a given distribution okay so let's
let's do that so we assume that I can I
can sample independent uh realization of
my distribution PX okay so I'm going to
call my samples X1 up to
xn and I'm going to assume that they are
independent and identically distributed
and the whole point of sampling method
is that now that you have those samples
you can estimate all sorts of statistics
about your distribution so uh by
essentially this is called the law of
large numbers what it tells you is that
the uh the empirical average uh of those
samples will converge to
the you know distribution expectation
like the actual expectation of your
distri
ution um and this will happen if you
have sufficiently many samples and for
those who care it's like almost sure
convergence uh but if you don't know
what this means it's really not
important for our
purpose H so this is this empirical uh
this empirical average here is called a
multical estimator of the
expectation and um you can also uh
estimate all sorts of integrals with uh
with with this method um I won't I won't
go into the details of this but you can
yeah looking forward to to the next to
the next lecture so this is the high
level idea of of sampling
methods
um okay does that make sense yeah all
good
okay okay so now we're going to jump
into variational
inference uh as another way to do a
imate
inference um so varal inference is a a
specific instance of variational methods
variational methods are sort of
a like um a broad category of approaches
to transform a given problem into an
optimization
problem um so the first example of
that is so now we're sort of out of the
realm of inference and even probability
we just uh looking at variational
methods as as a whole so one example of
the variational approach would be to
transform a uh a problem of finding a
solution to a linear
system and so you transform this problem
into an optimization
problem so here it's uh it's quite
direct to see that these two uh these
two things are are equivalent right so
if you if you solve um this linear
system uh you also solve this uh
optimization problem and vice
versa um so we have transformed the
problem of solving a linear system into
an optimization
problem another example is uh with
differential equations so um that's uh
so in some so I'm absolutely not an
expert on this but in some cases you can
transform uh the problem of solving a
differential equation as a a problem of
minimizing a functional so a functional
is a function that takes as input
another function and you uh you want to
minimize this functional so you try to
find a function that minimizes this
functional and this is analogous
to like newon and lran physics if you
guys know what this is otherwise it's
not a problem um so what is interesting
for us with this perspective is that
when you see the problem as an
optimization problem uh the sorts of it
opens up new strategies to approximate
solution to the problem
um okay so we're going we're going to do
that for for inference now so we're
going to apply this logic of of uh of
variational methods to the problem of
probabilistic
inference um
so uh so what we're going to do is we're
going to transform the inference problem
into an optimization
problem how are we going to do that so
to explain that I will consider the
example that I have introduced before so
you have this deep generative model so
again pz is just a gan and P of x given
Z is Gan with a mean outputed by a
neural
network and and now we want to compute
the posterior P of Z given x0 which we
saw was
intractable so the idea would be to uh
minimize some sort of distance between
distribution this is called the K
Divergence it's defined as such you
don't have to understand like the
details of exactly like what this means
you can try to you can try to think
about it but the idea is that this is
almost like you can you can think of
this as a distance between two
distribution um so it's not exactly
distance almost like almost like a
distance and so you have this nice
property that this uh function is always
bigger or equal to zero and it's zero if
and only if both both distributions are
equal and what we're going to do is
we're going to try to find a
distribution Q which is as close as
possible to the posterior that we're
trying to
estimate uh and what we're going to do
is we're we're going to pick this um
this family of of distribution to be
simple um in a way that like this
minimization problem becomes tractable
okay because of course if you don't
don't uh if she don't uh constrain this
uh you know the the family of
distribution over which you optimize um
the the solution to this problem is just
to like set Q to be P of Z given x0 to
be the posterior and of course it
wouldn't mean that like this
optimization problem is as hard as um
actually Computing the posterior so what
we typically do is we uh pick a simp
simple family of the distribution to
make our life
simple uh so that's what we're going to
see uh but of course it's not clear how
to actually perform this
minimization um because you know P of Z
given X zero the thing that we don't
want to compute actually appears in this
expression so how do we how do we
compute this this minan how do we
minimize this this
expression um so this is what we're
going to
do so here's the
trick um we're going to rewrite this K
Divergence in a nice way so here in the
first equality here I'm just applying
the definition of what is a kale
Divergence so I can write it as
expectation of log qz minus log P of Z
in x0 so I'm just using simple property
of logs and here I'm using uh the
definition of a uh of a of a conditional
distribution to go from this line line
to this line so uh essentially like this
is the
numerator and this is the denominator of
this conditional okay and again I apply
property of logs to like breaking down
into a sum and I get this and now I sort
of regroup terms in a in a useful way so
I will group these terms
together um and essentially when I take
the expect expectation of of this term I
get the scale between qz and
pz um here essentially I I I I do
nothing right I'm just using the the
linearity of expectation I get I get
this term here and since this term here
does not depend on Q I can just put it
out of the
expectation so now I have this uh new
expression which happens to be equal to
this
one um and the nice thing here
is that um first of all this term does
not depend on Q so if I want to minimize
this I can just work with this term
right because this this is a this is
this is just a constant so I can forget
about this I can just minimize this with
respect to q and what we're going to do
is we're going to pick the family of
this solution to be nice in a way that I
can actually minimize this that's that's
kind of the that's kind of the
trick and this is like a very general
idea that you can apply in all all sorts
of of set things um so you might have
noticed that I haven't used um you know
the the like the specifics of the deep
generative model that I have uh shown
before right I I you know I'm talking
about this like I I haven't used like
this right in my derivation so it it
works for any uh for any inference
problem
almost um and so that's a very general
idea but like the devils are in the
details it's going so the the devils are
going to be about how do we choose this
family of distribution so that this
problem becomes
tractable uh so to illustrate that we're
going to uh sort of build our build
towards the variational auto encoder um
and uh so many of you might already know
it but uh yeah we're we're going to see
it now um so in order to get to the
variational encoder three ingredients
are are missing the first one being as I
said we have to choose this variational
family que and um we're going to see
also that variational encoders are
performing amortized inference and we
will also see how to actually learn the
parameters of of the model um so so yeah
that's what is um ahead of
us so any questions so far everything's
clear don't be
shy
okay okay so in uh the vanilla
VA um we take the variational family Q
to be the set of Gan distribution with a
diagonal Co variance in other words
which we take Q to be of this form okay
so simple distribution and you know
diagonal Co variant very
simple of course um in general the
distribution that trying to approximate
won't be gausian okay so um it means
that the when we perform this
minimization uh there will always be
like you know some some Gap it's it's
only an appro an approximation we will
never be able to like get exactly the
right posterior so that's why we we have
uh we have this inequality
here uh but okay so we won't be able to
get exactly the right posterior but at
least it will make our problem tractable
so that's kind of the the trade of
here
um
okay okay so amorti INF
so in the way I formulated things so far
um essentially for each sample XI when
I'm estimating P of Z given XI I have to
solve this minimization problem which we
saw is equivalent to to this one right
so now I have a bunch of of I floating
around right it's just that for for each
sample XI I have to perform this
minimization to um to estimate my
posterior um so I have to fit Q Qi for
each sample
XI um so an armatized inference instead
of doing that um we are um
essentially parameterizing
uh the relationship between X and the
parameters of Q so let me say that again
essentially we will learn a function
that takes XI and outputs the parameters
of
Qi okay um so usually it's a neural
network okay and um the reason it's
called Uh amortized inference is that we
we pay like a we pay a fixed cost right
so we just pay the like the cost of
having one R Network and then I can add
samples and you know the I don't have
more parameters adding to to my model
whereas if I stick with this formulation
for each new sample I have to add a you
know the parameters of of
Qi which are essentially the mean and
the co-variance um so that's why we call
it amorti inference we sort of amortize
the cost over over samples um and so
yeah precisely what we what we have now
is uh Q of Z given X where um the mean
is outputed by uh by some function of X
and this function m is going to be a
noral network and similarly for U the
the variance okay um so so that's the
idea of amortized inference does that
make sense so far I mean yeah details
are sort of coming uh shortly but
yeah okay so we went from our original
variational inference problem where we
had to perform this minimization
individually for h i to this um
amortized inference uh uh
formulation uh and uh so now we can ask
okay how am I going to um perform this
maximization and what we're going to do
is simply
apply stochastic gradient descent to do
that uh to to optimize the the
parameters of of my Q of Z and X the
parameters of those networks so remember
like muz and S are the neural
networks um used to Output the
parameters of my varal posterior okay Q
so I want to optimize those so how am I
how am I how am I going to do that I
need to be able to compute gradient of
the L of course if I want to comp if I
want to do gradient
descent uh so it turns out that this
term is easy to deal with because um
because we chose Q To
Be A gaussian and P of Z is also gussian
you have a close form solution for the K
okay you can actually write it down and
to compute the gradient you can just
apply automatic differentiation to to
that expression so that's good we we can
compute the the gradient of this term
um this term is a little bit more uh
tricky because we have this uh this
nasty uh expectation here and uh you
know we cannot really bring the gradient
inside the expectation here because
um we're taking the gradient with
respect to parameters of of Q here and
um so yeah it makes your life a little
bit harder so to get around this problem
we're going to apply the rep the
reparameterization trick which we're
going to see
now okay so reparation trick what is it
um so uh we're going
to rewrite our sample Z in this form
okay so the ideas Z is sampled from my
distribution Q of Z given X if and only
if Z is uh written as such where Epsilon
is some uh some white noise Some
gaussian Noise here uh so it's easy to
check that this is true for for gaussian
um and uh when I when you notice that it
allows you to rewrite this expectation
in this form okay so what happened here
now my expectation so here my
expectation was with respect to z now my
expectation is with respect to
Epsilon and what I did is I Z by its
reparameterized form okay
and okay so those two expression are
equal now I can try to take the gradient
with respect to the parameters of my uh
of my neural
networks and what happens here is that
uh because now I have like Epsilon here
which does not depend on the parameters
I can just bring the gradient inside the
expectation um and yeah this this
gradient can be computed uh using
automatic differentiation and you can
estimate this um this expectation using
mtic Carlo
estimation so that's that's the that's
the trick and it works for not just Gan
but for also all sorts of other
distribution as long as you can uh
reparameterize it um in a similar in a
similar
way um yeah question can can you
maybe oh yeah say that again I will
repeat your question yeah no no it's
fine it's fine you can stay sit I'll
just repeat your
question
yeah yeah yeah yeah so yeah yeah yeah so
so there is like I'm skipping a lot of M
mathematical details here like of course
if you want to swap oh yeah yeah I have
to repeat the question okay so the
question is why can I swap the gradient
and the expectation here um and um the
the person in the audience said that you
know we have to check conditions like
like dominated convergence and and and
things like that of course I'm skipping
a lot of details here uh like uh when
you swap a limit with an integral there
are all sorts of of details that you
need to to uh worry about I'm not
worrying about this now this is fairly
standard so I just I guess trust the
common wisdom but of course like if you
wanted to be super rigorous you would
have to check those conditions but for
now we we don't have to care about
it uh but the the point is that you
clearly couldn't do it before right so
because because the the like the
expectation is taken with respect to a a
random variable that depends on the
parameter with respect to which you're
differentiating so that that's where
like things break so but you're right
like if you wanted to be rigorous you
would have to check uh this that you
indeed have a right
to uh swap these
operators uh
okay okay um so let me just step back so
I showed you that uh we can compute the
gradient of this expression okay so it
means we can perform
uh stochastic gradient Ascent in that
case because we're
maximizing uh to to perform um to
perform my inference okay my approximate
inference
um do I have to say something more
here yeah okay so all of that was just
about inference right just about
estimating P of Z given x uh I haven't
talked about how to actually learn the
parameters of my generative model
um so that's what I'm going to discuss
now how do we
learn yeah okay so that's what I said
already
um now we investigate how to estimate
the parameters so the first so if you're
trying to learn parameters for model the
first thing you know to think about is
like can I just do maximum lik
estimation at least that's what I'm
thinking about always um and so if you
want to do maximum likelihood estimation
you have to you know
compute the you have to maximize this
this log probability right respect to to
the parameters of your model it just
turns out that for this you know more
involved model this is hard to do right
because if you if you write down this
log P of X you'll have like again an
integral with like a nonlinear function
and it's it's not clear exactly how to
compute the gradient of this thing um so
what we're going to do
instead uh is we will maximize a lower
bound on this lug
likelihood so let's see how to do that
so here I'm just reusing some
computations that that we saw before
like so earlier we saw that we can write
this uh Divergence between Q of Z given
X and P of Z given X in this form okay
um so I'm just it's something that we
already
saw
um and what I'm doing here is I'm just
using the fact that the kale is always
bigger or equal to zero to uh to get to
this inequality to this lower bound
right so if this guy here is bigger or
equal to zero I can sort of you know
take these two terms and like send them
on the left hand side of the inequality
and I get this inequality
okay uh so that's a low bound on my on
my log likelihood um so and and this is
is called the evidence St bound the
elbow and uh
so turns out that uh this bound is tight
when the of course when the
variational posterior Q of Z given X is
equal to the actual posterior P of Z
given
x uh but you know as we said like
because of all because we we we have um
because we've made uh you know
simplifying assumptions about the
posterior
we might not be able to get this
equality as we saw
already um and so to maximize this lower
bound we're going to take uh you know
the gradient with respect to the
parameters of the generative model P
which which is essenti which is
essentially the the the the parameter of
your uh of your neural network
here and
uh so so yeah so to maximize the elbow
essentially and yeah I didn't mention
that but this is exactly the same thing
that we were maximizing to perform
inference before so I'm talking about
like these two things as the in a sense
in in a separ in a separate way right
I'm talking about inference so Computing
Q of Z given
X and um maximizing the likelihood of my
generative model but you can actually do
both of these things simultaneously can
just maximize this lower bound with
respect to both the generative model p
and your inference model q and that's
what we do in inational inference we in
in inational Auto encoders I should say
um we we just maximize this lower bound
with respect to p and Q in the hope that
this is going to push up uh the the the
likelihood so it's sort of like yeah a
way to do maximum likelihood um and this
is very similar to expectation
maximization which is a classical
algorithm uh except in in in EM usually
what you do is you alternate between
optimizing with respect to q and
optimizing with respect to p and in some
cases you have close form solutions to
that so you just alternate between
between optimize with respect to Q
optimize with respect to P alternate
like that here we just do everything uh
together and we we optimize with
gradient Ascent instead uh so that's
that's that's the VES that's that's the
perspective um so yeah I'm I'm done so
yeah maybe before doing recap like any
questions on this that was clear
or
no
okay yeah okay to conclude we saw what
probabilistic inference is we uh we we
saw um you know simple cases of exact
inference uh then we saw more subtle
cases where uh computation is more
challenging we saw sampling methods as a
way to sort of uh go around these
computational difficulties we spend some
time talking about variational inference
and we built up to uh varal encoders
which is like a very popular method
these days well maybe not as popular as
they once were but it's a classic method
I guess so yeah if there's no more
questions I guess I I'm done thank
you
thank you Sebastian is there any
question for Sebastian last questions
that about prob s
conference okay uh so that's it for the
uh for this for the sessions for this
morning uh so thank you for attending we
are going to be back at at uh 2 p.m uh
this afternoon for two new sessions on
uh prob on sampling sorry and
reinforcement learning so yeah have a
good
lunch so
uh all right so the food is back there
in the corner I highly recommend Random
Access let's just not you know have a
queue of 150 people just uh just go for
the food um that's going to be more
efficient
e
okay Mike D
online
mik are online yes M
online mik
online
Mike there in the
room
he
what yeah my milc only
from
annoying
right
yes hello everyone welcome back from the
lunch I hope you got some energy and we
continue our day with with sampling
methods and uh uh yeah today we have
Pablo lemas presenting sampling methods
for us Pablo is postd do researcher uh
at Mila and several other universities
which I forgot
sorry uh but yeah I'm very curious to
listen to you about simping methods the
floor is yours yeah thanks uh yeah I
have a lot of and unfortunately large
number of affiliations um but it's okay
for Sasha not to remember them um yeah
so thanks for Sasha and everyone else
for having me and for inviting me to
talk about sampling methods um so yeah
my background so I'm in in udm and I'm
in the astrophysics group so my
background is in astrophysics um and I'm
going to talk about sampling methods um
drawing a bit from examples from
astrophysics and I'll try to
justify why I think that the
astrophysics community and the cosmology
Community which is the branch of
astrophysics have developed some of the
of the best mcmc and so on method
and it's I think it's because of the
natur nature of the problems we're we're
trying to solve um I'll also mostly talk
about continuous uh problems again from
experience but basically everything I'll
say applies very naturally to discreet
problems as well right so this should
follow up from um like continue from The
Talks by by Tristan and by by Sebastian
this morning um and that they they kind
of set up um uh the the framework for
probabalistic uh problems and now we
have a probability distribution we're
trying to generate samples so um not
working yes it okay um so I'm going to
try to First make it clear what the
problem it is that we're trying to solve
um and the reason I'm going to be um
quite obvious to most people on this is
that I've had kind of um loss in
translations situations with people
especially who come from machine
learning on on what is it that we're
trying to do here
so I'm going to adopt a a basent
framework um so you wouldn't have to do
this for my part of the talk for the
sampling part um but I think it's just
nicely consistent with what came before
so you have some prior P of X that's
your prior knowledge on the parameters
you're interested in um and you have a
likelihood so you've observed some data
y um and now you update you want to
update your P of x to a p of x given y
through base theorem um using the
likelihood um so just to be on the same
page um is there like something to point
with in that equation basically the
thing on the left we're going to call
the posterior distribution um the thing
on the top P of Y given X is the
likelihood P of X is the prior I think
we have a point coming um and P of Y in
the bottom thank
you P of Y in the bottom is the what we
call the bent evidence or marginal
likelihood um it was mentioned by
Tristan by other people before um and it
will be important later in the talk as
well so just keep this equation in mind
base theorem I think it's been in every
talk so far I'm sure in more talks in
the future um so here's an example
distribution that we might want to
sample
from and I'm going to show an orange
potential samples you could get um so
this obviously would be wrong um so you
would have missed one of the modes so
that's bad
sampling that's also bad sampling you've
captured both modes but you haven't
fully modeled the modes correctly you
haven't reached the Peaks it's bad
sampling but importantly and this is a
thing where I've had people disagree on
what we trying to do this is bad
sampling as well so here you have catch
both modes you have sampled the paks
very well so you have the the maximum of
both modes really clearly but this is
not what we're trying to do right um and
I think the reason that again this might
be obvious to some people but the reason
why there's sometimes misunderstanding
is that if you're trying to I don't know
come up with something to play chess or
you know the sign a drug you want the
best you want the peak you want the best
solution um but in in this kind of
problems and Tristan mentioned
self-driving cars an example I'll draw
from from astrophysics for other
examples um you want the whole
distribution you want to understand this
the shape of the whole distribution
really well so you want this right
that's that's the Target and anything
else um so this we would call
overconfident you you've Mis
misunderstood how wide your errors
should
be um right so
cosmology um this is again this is the
example that I draw from because is my
background but also I think it's pretty
fun um so maybe you'll also learn
something that you didn't expect to
learn today um so in cosmology the the
the overall problem we're trying to
solve is the
following you have a model that
parameterizes the evolution of the
Universe from initial conditions to the
large scale structure we see today so to
galaxies basically and that model works
with only five parameters which is
actually quite remarkable um so
basically when you specify this is
basically the the density of what you
could call regular matter matter that we
know from Earth and dark matter um you
specify the pble constant is the
expansion rate
um and you specified some things about
the initial conditions which are physics
based you can then basically generate
initial conditions and simulate all the
way from The Big Bang all the way till
today so the problem we're trying to
solve in cosmology is to do inference of
those parameters we want to understand
those parameters um and again I'll make
it clear we don't want the best value we
want to understand how well we can
measure
them so the nice thing about working in
this field is that you get pretty
pictures a time um so in this one uh you
don't see it super clearly there it will
become more clear you start with initial
conditions which is a cou in random
field um and you let gravity do its
thing so it's going to start collapsing
there will be over densities in the
initial field it will start collapsing
and eventually you will start to see the
cosmic web hopefully maybe on the TV is
more clear um in my screen it looks very
nice um the lights the lights are
available so you can look at it more cly
later uh but basically the thing is that
uh gravity will start collapsing things
and eventually you will get something
that looks like the C Cosmic web which
doesn't this one looks maybe better um
so the point here is that when you
change the value of these parameters the
universe starts to look different so it
might look more clumpy um it will have
maybe more
galaxies so in the cosmic web when the
notes of this web is where galaxies form
so when you see galaxies you're kind of
looking at the notes of the cosmic web
um so again the problem is an inference
problem you're trying to do inference of
these parameters given this
observations and so because the model
goes from basically the very beginning
of the universe till today you can look
at the universe today you can look at
galaxies you can also look at something
called the microwave background which is
an observation of the universe very
early on um these days you can even look
at gravitational waves and and things
like that um and the problem you're
trying to solve again this is just an
example everything I'm going to talk
about is more generic but the problem
you're trying to solve is given an
observation why um you some you compress
it in some way um now you you fix the
parameter so you pick how much stack
matter there is the expansion rate and
so on um you make a prediction for this
data and this data you may not be able
to see super clearly but it has error
bars um so you have an understanding of
your uncertainty in this data points um
and so you're playing the game of
changing these parameters and and that
changes your predictions until you find
good
fit and you end up with things like this
so you might have seen this in other
field so this is um one and two Sigma
Contour like 68 95% confidence levels of
these different parameters I was talking
about before and the point I wanted to
drive home here with example is that the
reason that we care not we don't just
care about the middle of this we care
about the whole thing and the reason we
really care in cosmology and the reason
that cosmology has been really good at
developing mcmc methods is that we can
only see the one Universe right um so if
your particle physics you can just redo
your example you can be a frequen you
can just do your example a million times
and and just do really bad statistics
and things will work out because you
have enough
data but in cosmology we have the one
observation so we have to really really
get the most out of of it so sometimes
these eror bars actually represent the
limit to what we will ever get to know
from this one data point about this
parameters so it's important we don't
just care about the peak of distribution
we care about the whole distribution and
in fact this kind of um the generes that
we call them tell you for example that
perhaps you cannot measure one parameter
you can only measure some certain
combination of them so there's there's
physics and there's interesting science
in there right so that's my my
motivating
example um
and then I'll start talking about how
you actually do this okay so you have
some kind of distribution you can
evaluate now you want to generate
samples how do you do that um and the
simplest perhaps the simplest way of
doing it is with the rejection
sampling so rejection I think it's the
simplest maybe there's something
simpler I don't think it's much simpler
than this um so in rejection sampling so
this is back to the Target distribution
we had
before what you do here is you're going
to randomly sample your prior you're
going to sample X and you're also going
to randomly sample P of X so you're
going to get points that basically
populate the space um and all you're
doing now is you're going to select the
ones that are under the curve so you're
going to reject plus the name the pink
ones in this case and you're going to
keep the red ones um and then when you
do a histogram of those um you get with
something that looks pretty good so that
works uh rejection sampling does work um
but you can probably already think that
if I had a very very small mode I'm very
likely to hit it by rejection sampling
um and if I had multiple Dimensions this
is going to scale horrendously bad so
that's the reason that no one ever in
practice uses it but if you have a
simple enough problem why not um the
thing people use in more practice is
mcmc so that's Mark of chain Monte Carlo
um I've talked to people especially um
people perhaps younger than myself so my
PhD was mostly doing mcmc um and I feel
like there sometimes younger people have
only heard about mcmc in the context of
you know mcmc is so bad we have to go
with something better mcmc is terrible
mcmc is good mcmc is good in the right
problems mcmc is not a multi-use tool
but in the right problems mcmc is good
mcmc does what mcmc is supposed to do so
I'm trying to convince you of that um so
the the key thing here in the name is
Mark of chain uh so Tristan already
introduced the concept of marov chain
and he knows markof chains better than
me but um I have a slide as well and
then made a pretty picture so I thought
I would keep it um and a mark of Change
You just defined by a state a state
space um so just a bunch of states in
the case of my drawing is three some
probability to go from one to another
and the fact that these probabilities
are um don't have a memory so they don't
remember what came before that's called
the marro property um and the kind of
Mark of chain we're going to be
interested in is one that is reversible
so it has a stationary distribution so
if you you know let it evolve for long
enough it will reach some kind of
stationary distribution some probability
of S1 probability of S2 probability of
S3 um and it satisfied what's called
detail
balance so that just means that the
probability of S1 times the probability
of jumping to S2 is equal to the
opposite I'm mentioning that here
because it's important for Metropol say
thingss which is one I'm going to talk
about next but also it's important to G
flow Nets um so that will come up
tomorrow I suspect when people start
about G flow
nets all right so Metropolis Hastings is
one example of mcmc algorithm it's
probably the one you've heard about
before because is the most commonly used
um and it's it's an algorithm that has a
lot of literature um so you will find a
lot of tricks a lot of implementations
and so on and again for the right Tye of
problem it works perfectly
so the idea is that you're going to
create a mark of chain like those ones
where the stationary distribution is
going to be equal to your target
distribution you it should actually be x
given y there um so you start with some
initial point x z
um if you have knowledge of your target
distribution you can pick it wisely you
don't have to um and then you start with
a proposal distribution so that's going
to be a way to go from x0 to some other
point um so in this case in a continuous
example you often have do some kind of
perhaps a normal distribution around x0
with some some standard deviation if you
have a discrete problem for example you
might have a sequence and your proposal
might just be changing some some
characters in your sequence or something
like that um The Proposal would just
affect the efficiency of the algorithm
but the algorithm will and over infinite
time work even with a really bad
proposal um and then all you do is you
propose points from this proposal
distribution and you accept it with
probability um and that probability just
means if your proposal took you to a
point of higher likelihood you accept it
immediately if it took you to one of
lower likelihood you can still accept it
um and the probability to accept it is
just a ratio of the two um so you have
here a little animation so in this
animation the red arrows are going to be
rejections and the green are going to be
acceptance um and you can see there that
all that you do is you just generate
randomly um your proposal here is quite
broad so you reject a lot of points um
but all that you all that happens from
that is not that you get biased
inference in any ways just that you're
wasting a lot of computing time in in
bad proposals um but the algorithm works
and if you let it run for long enough
you will have the stationary
distribution which is this banana in
this case and so you will have samples
from this
distribution um tricks to make it work
better the most obvious one is to change
your proposal to make it
better um in a continuous case you often
can learn for example some kind of Co
variance Matrix you can even use deep
learning here so I'm not going to have
deep learning in general in this talk
but I have seen implementations where
you use deep learning to propose points
um the the thing with tuning The
Proposal is that if the proposal still
if your acceptance R is too high you're
going to walk this distribution really
slowly um if your if your acceptance
race is too low you're going to just
spend a lot of time rejecting points um
so I don't think there's a hard rule but
in my personal experience um
practitioners aim for like a point three
or so so you accept one and three points
um that works relatively well um and
again the easiest way to do it is to
just somehow learn a CO variance Matrix
here that that adapts to to aim for
that3 acceptance rate so that's pretty
to do um you often use multiple Walkers
you might have heard the ter Walkers the
term Walkers comes from the fact that
you're just walking around this
distribution um if you have multiple
Walkers that has multiple advantages
first of all you generate samples in
parallel um but more importantly um
there is this this calculation which is
called the Gman ruin diagnostic um and
Gman ruin will basically tell you um if
the stationary distribution that your
multiple walkers have reached is the
same um so it serves as a stopping
Criterion it tells you when you have
when you can stop
sampling
um and finally you might have write the
concept of bur
in um so imagine in this case this is
multimodal I'll talk about multimodality
later but ignore that for now um imagine
you start in a bad point here where the
likely is very low your mcmc will
eventually take you to one of the modes
and then you start moving around um so
if now you plot the the prob actually
this will be the minus probability um it
starts um really low again this is minus
probability bad labeling um and it very
quickly drops and then it just stays
pretty stable so this means you've reach
the stationary distribution um these
points are points here before you reach
stationary distribution so you should
not keep them they're not really samples
from distribution so what people do is
burn in some of your chain so just
remove some of the points um which were
before the stationary
distribution um there might be a hard
rule on how to do this in practice I
think you can just eyeball it pretty
easily um and I wanted to mention an
implementation that I quite like um so
there's multiple there's one called MCE
I don't know how you pronounce it um but
this one is one that was made by
cosmologists um but you can actually use
it for anything so it has all of the
tricks s like a adapting proposal and
and Gman rubben convergence and so on um
it's it's it's written to be
parallelizable as well and it was
written to be in cosmology so the short
name has cosmology in there but actually
you can just put any likelihood in there
and in fact we recently had a paper with
Sasha and with other people some of the
organizers uh where we compared gfl net
Sasha not about this paper later in the
week but we compare gonet with mcmc
amongst other things and the mcmc part
we we use this cosmology code so you can
just put a a molecule likelihood in a
work chest as well so that's one of the
my mcmc runs for
ibuprofen um again Sasha will talk more
about this paper and if you're
interested in using this code um you can
find it online you can talk to me as
well uh that's Metropolis H thingss so
that's probably the most commonly used
um mcmc method but there's others um so
this one is called Metropolis adjusted
lunchable algorithm or Mala if you
shorten it um so this one you can use
only if you have access to the gradient
of the of the likelihood the gradient of
your target
distribution so if you have
differentiable programming and you've
written your your target distribution
differentiably you can use this um and
you've probably heard of lunch Dynamics
in terms of defusion and so on is the
similar idea so you're going to start
with a point you're going to propose a
new one Us in lunch B Dynamics so
something like o marama or something
like that um and then you can calculate
a an acceptance probability similar to
the Metropolis hting one that is going
to give you the right stationary
distribution um so again the penalty is
that you need the gradient but it
actually scales better than Metropolis H
thingss so if you have gradients you can
use that or you can use hamiltonian mon
Carlo um which is pretty similar in fact
I think there's some papers that say
that fundamentally they're kind of doing
the same thing um it gives you much
nicer animations by the way this is are
not my animations I found these online
and they're amazing you can play with it
and I spent I wasted much more time than
I should have uh playing with this um H
so this Ison Monte Carlo so people with
a physics background will be familiar
with Hamilton's equations um hamiltonian
Monte Carlo is a similar idea you start
with a point you create like a fake
momentum actually variable um and you
also assign a mass Matrix and the mass
Matrix is a hyperparameter of this this
algorithm um and then you have a mass
you have a position you have a momentum
so you just um solve Hamilton's
equations which basically do Dynamics
where in this case the potential is
going to be minus log
probability and you can show that that
will also give you the right sary
distribution um again scale is much
better than Metropolis Hasting so some
people in the astrophysics Community
have used this in many thousands of
Dimensions I'm sure this also happens I
mean I think if there's even BN papers
doing HMC so it it scales to very high
dimensionals pretty well um it's not
that good at mode finding I'll talk
about that later as well um but yeah the
idea is that the the tricky thing here
is to tune the mass Matrix but if you
can do that it works really well um
another hyper parameter is the length of
this trajectory so you're solving
Dynamics here um and the length
if it's too short you end up with a
random walk and if it's too long it
becomes really inefficient there's an
variation of the algorithm called the no
u-turn sampler that automatically um
Tunes the length um so there's also very
good implementations of all of
these um and yeah that's mcmc methods um
so now I'm going to talk about another
type of
method just called nested sampling
um so nested sampling is something that
we use a lot in in astrophysics and it's
not very well known outside and I think
it's a Pity because it's a really good
algorithm for again for the right
problems it's not going to you know I'm
not saying drop def flow NS and do this
I'm going to justify that but for the
right problem this is a really really
good algorithm um and let me justify it
so there's two reasons why it's good the
first one is multimodality so mcmc does
not do multimodality that applies to HMC
to all of this um and the reason for
that you can kind of see it um imagine
that I'm solving this multimodal thing
um so I'm trying to cover this modes and
I start here like before and this
animation now is going to give me the
mcmc so I start I go towards the mode I
sample it now there's a non-zero chance
that I'm going to take this jump but
it's a very small chance right because
there's a small probability of going
towards smaller likelihood but I have to
to multiple of those to to hit another
mode um and then I would have to do that
again and again so over infinite time
mcmc will cover everything um over
practical times it will not so mcmc is
really bad for multimodality it
basically in practice gets stuck in
modes um so a solution to this is Nest
sampling the other reason why you can
use it is to calculate devation evidence
so if you remember before in base
theorem I mentioned that the denominator
is called devation evidence marginal
likelihood um and you can also rewrite
it by very simple algebra as the
integral over this just to enforce that
this is normalized um and
so the the original reason Nest sampling
was was created was to solve this
integral so this integral will can be
very high dimensional it be as high
dimensional as X um and it's intractable
in principle but in practice there a
trick to to to be able to do
it um let me tell you a bit about why
you want to find that integral in the
first place right because it's been
mention that there's this um bent
evidence um and we so far kind of
neglected and in fact if you just want
samples you probably only care about the
ratio of these between samples so you
don't actually care about the
normalization but the normalization has
important information as well
so Tristan mentioned coin flips I'm also
going to draw on coin flips as a classic
statistic
example and so the main reason people
use theas evidence is to compare models
right so imagine that I've done a bunch
of coin flips and I have two models one
is that my coin is biased and one is
that it is not um so what I want to know
is what is the likelihood what is the
ratio of the probability that my model
oop of model one and bias given the data
to model two which is bias given the
data um that's the kind of basent way of
solving this
problem um and now I'm going to do some
very very basic algebra so bear with me
um so you can write base theorem for
either of these ratios pretty
straightforward and then you can
actually take the
ratio you end up with those two terms
there and what you're going to notice is
that we have P of D here and P of D here
those do not depend on the model so
those go away um and so you end up with
something like this um and now here you
have this ratio P of M1 to P of M2 so
that would be the it would basically be
the the the prior probability you have
on each model so how much how much more
likely do you think one model is with
respect to the other um so if you're
assuming that you're going unbiased
yourself if you think that they're both
equally likely that means those are the
same so those also go away and therefore
the ratio that you want is the ratio of
the bent evidences so if you calculate
the evidence for each one of these
models and you take the ratio that's
going to tell you which one is more
likely given the data that you've
seen so here's an example more
interesting maybe that the coin flips
marginally only um which is I've seen
this data f of x and I'm going to try to
fit it with a model and my different
models are going to be polinomial of
different orders now um so Order series
is going to be a horizontal line um and
here I'm going to plot I didn't label
this it's the first time I use this
slide so there's a lot of box but there
should be a a set here um so this is
going to be the evidence okay so order
zero that's just a line so that's my
best fit that's the evidence there not
very good um now I I take a second model
which is model one um so that's an order
one polinomial slightly better evidence
so slightly
preferred
quadratic um so that now has three terms
so it's a little bit more complex the
evidence goes up it's this third order
uh as it turns out perhaps whoever
designed this problem made it through
order um so it fits perfectly so the
evidence really Peaks and now here's
where the evidence the Bas evidence and
the Bas way of doing model comparison
becomes really cool is that bation model
comparison will penalize unnecessary
complexity um so when I go to order four
what's going to happen is that my best
fit because again I designed this to be
a third order the fourth order
coefficient is basically going to be
zero um and what I'm going to have is
that now I have a parameter which
actually I don't need um so that model
gets penalized it gets penalized because
it has more parameters than I actually
need I have I have enough with four
parameters I don't need the fifth um and
if I do a fifth order the polinomial I
get penalized even more because now I'm
adding an extra parameter that I also
don't need um so the point of patient
model comparison is that it will give me
the best model um with the least
necessary
complexity um and this is something that
again perhaps not useable for every for
every discipline but again back to the
astrophysics example and I'm sure
there's many others in other Sciences um
I don't want a model of the universe
that is adding a parameter there that is
unnecessarily complex I want to to
create a model as simple as possible and
in fact people who are into philosophy
might have heard of alam Tracer people
often refer to this as the Alam racer
penalty as well not don't love the term
but um if you like this kind of stuff by
the way um this part of the talk and a
lot of my talk is inspired by this book
which is excellent I I really
recommend uh and another way that you
can use the evidence this is a bit of
self publicity for me I'm still post so
I have to do publicity every time I can
um is uh you can you can use use it for
another problem which is Imagine now
that I have two observations so this we
came up with this in the context of
astrophysics as before imagine I've seen
the universe with the micro background
and with galaxies and I have a model
that is supposed to explain both um you
can use the evidence to tell you how
likely it is that both of these
observations would come from the same
model um and the point is that if that's
very unlikely that means that your model
is probably wrong so you need a new
model um so we came up with a way to use
devation evidence to quantify this um if
you want more I have a linked paper
there but if you want to hear more about
that um you can talk to me later as
well right so that's why you use the
vent evidence um but now let me tell
about how I actually calculate
it because it does remain a very high
dimensional difficult
integral so nested sampling relies on
the realization so so you have a prior
distribution in this case it would be
this box um and you have a likelihood
that you can evaluate uh and next examp
comes from the realization that every
Point defines some volume which is the
volume of all points with higher
likelihood so in this case this point
here defines this volume um and so what
you can do is you can take your um your
horrible very high dimensional integral
in this case two dimensionals it's not
so bad but imagine that it's higher um
and you can now basically write every X
in terms of this prior volume so this
prior volume will go from one which is
when you have the whole box to zero
which is when you've reached the maximum
of the distribution again this is the
volume that is higher likelihood than
the current Point um and so you can turn
this this very high dimensional integral
into one dimensional integral which is
from volume zero to volume one the whole
box so all you need is a set of points
of increasing um monot increasing X or
mon monotonically decreasing which what
we're going to do and then you can just
rewrite this integral as a
quadrature and and you you're
done so the way the algorithm works is
you start this result integral that you
want as
zero um now you're going to pick the the
lowest likelihood points so you generate
a bunch of points from the from the
prior and you call those the Live points
and I don't particularly like this name
but I didn't come up with the algorithm
um you Pi the lowest lik point and
you're going to replace it with a point
that has higher likelihood so basically
you're going to sample this blob here
uniformly um and you're going to pick a
point from that blob again uniformly the
uniformly part is is key and is what
makes this difficult right otherwise you
could just take the gradient and go to
to the maximum but you you have to make
it uniform um you're going to do that
and then if if you really did a uniform
um the way the amount by which you've
compressed this volume um you can
approximate like that um the details are
in a bunch of papers which I can point
you to um and because of this quadrature
that I have here then you can update
your set estimate like
that you repeat repeat repeat and what's
going to happen um is that you're going
to basically slowly converge towards
higher likelihood regions because you're
always replacing with a better Point um
and eventually you're going to end up
with points concentrated on the higher
likelihood um so incidentally you can
actually use this for optimization and
it works pretty well
um but the the key thing is that not
only does it gives you this integral but
also if you weigh these points
appropriately again there's a bunch of
math here which I'm not showing but you
can look at the paper you weigh these
points appropriately you actually also
get samples from the distribution which
is what mcmc gives you so you end up
with both the integral and the samples
from the
distribution the difficult thing here is
that imagine at this fixed step I have
to uniformly sample from these three
blobs um so that's pretty difficult um
so you can think rejection sampling
that's the way way the original
algorithm was made um so you randomly
sample points and only accept when the
life fi is higher but obviously that's
extremely inefficient especially towards
the end um another method is to
basically build the lipoids around the
points that you already have um that
works better no ideal slice sampling
works really well um so the idea there
is that you're going to build slices
you're going to bounce up the walls um
again more of publicity because still a
postto is this paper that we're going to
put on the archive probably Friday I'm
hoping I've actually delaying that um
where we use the gradient of the
distribution to to do this task of
sampling of sampling from this um so we
use the gradient and we actually got
really good performance um so you can
here see here n samping in action right
so that's the truth this is
a like TW I don't know how many modes
there's a lot of modes um you capture
them all with sampling um this is one
that one of our PC students in the group
came up with which is a really
diabolical distribution and you do
really
well um this is comparing with something
called Fab which is one of the
state-of-the-art sampling methods using
deep learning again I'm not talking
about deep learning methods here because
I think the best one is probably G flet
and that's the whole point of the
workshop um but we do much better than
Fab we actually capture the most much
better um and you can actually combine
this with gfl Nets um so the paper will
be an archive probably on Friday which
is convenient because that's when you
will know everything there is to know
about gonet and so you can then go to
the paper and see how you can combine
these two things but I will not spoil
that
um and I'm almost done um I'll end up
with some more publicity this is the
last one um which is a paper that we had
recently on checking how good your
samples are whether your samples are
from the right distribution um so that
one was an icml um and yeah I don't want
to do on that too much so I want to
leave some time for questions so I
wanted to finish with with the little um
a little metaphor which is um I want to
make the point that gonets are really
good I'm not I'm not anti gonet quite
the opposite I'm working a lot on gonet
myself um but you know the way I like to
see it is you know G flet is like like a
really really cool tool that you can use
for multiple things like super nice and
new and multifunctional and we're going
to hear about all the functionality and
mcmt is like a hammer you know it's like
an oldfashioned Hammer but you know
sometimes just have a nail on the wall
and you could spend like a long time
looking at your drill and coming with
the right setting you just take your
hammer and you know bang it a couple of
times and just it it will do the work um
so sometimes it's worth not Reinventing
the wheel and for the right problems
mcmc nested sampling and these methods
are uh are just fine um so yeah I've put
my contact info there my slides are here
and I think they're also going to be
shared through the through the workshop
website and yeah there's still Sometimes
some questions for so
thanks thank you so much for the
excellent talk do we have any questions
in the
audience please go to the
mic So yeah thank you very very much for
your talk um sorry it's probably a
stupid question but I didn't really
understand when you talked about uh
basion evidence so you're doing the
ratio yeah but the marginal likelihood
is Con out right so you don't really
need the inter um sorry this is so this
is this is uh not very clear notation of
my part
so you have the okay so here the
notation is X is the parameters I'm
interested in yeah and Y is the data and
I kind of changed notation which is
really bad again this is the first time
I use these slides so this is good
feedback why here is an observation that
you have so in the next slide I'm going
to call that D which is really bad me um
so here what you have is now you have
the observation and you have models so I
guess implicitly when you do
this when you do this there's also a
model here on the right you're assuming
a model that has the parameters X um and
so what you have now is two different
parameters Each of which has so here P
of Y would I guess be the same as P of D
given M yeah um and the one that cancels
is p of D without given M so it's just
the probability of the of observing this
data isn't this the integral because
it's the marginal likelihood the P ofd
right is the marginal lack of PF given
the model
um the the again the we can it might be
easier with with the board but there's a
comma M here in everything in that
because I have parameters there's an
implicit model here that I'm assuming um
so in the in the case of the coins um
there's two of these one for the
unbiased model one for the biased model
the unbiased model doesn't have any
parameters and the bias model has one
parameter to is the bias um so there is
a p of Y given model one and P of Y
given model too um again might be easier
to do this with but it's it's a good
question and it points out my bad
notation here okay and yeah I have a
little question as well again on this
thing as well I didn't really understand
why polinomial with um I mean too much
complexity were penalized right so again
you can imagine uh again I always draw
from astrophysics but like you can
imagine in in any kind of scientific
model you I mean this is probably this
is you can get philosophical as maybe a
human bios but you prefer the science
ific explanation that's the simplest
right you prefer scientific explanation
that is not unnecessarily complex to
explain phenomena that you've observed
yeah um so the point of devation
evidence is that and this is in the
nature of you kind of when you do this
in the integral which is not here when
you do the integral if you have a
parameter that's not adding anything
you're still integrating over over the
prior in that parameter so it's going to
add some penalty for that complexity
that's why even even though the loss is
yeah so that's why the yeah exactly the
loss Remains the Same but I mean you can
even do the so the book that I pointed
out does the calculation for a ga for
gausian posteriors and that if you add a
new one that's not doing anything you
have a term that is the ratio to the on
the on the maximum and another one
that's the number of parameters so you
basically it's kind of similar to the
AIC the patient information criteria and
all these things and that it will
penalize complexity in that way as well
yeah thank you yeah I love this
than
any other
questions can go to
l a
question you mentioned about um
Metropolitan hting sampling and you
mentioned that we have the gradient of
the target distribution can you give an
example how we can have that yes good
question no Metropolis Hastings does not
assum a gradient but both the the lon
version and the hamiltonian Monte Carlo
version assume a gradient um and I mean
the the example would be in this
distribution in the Metropolis Hastings
version you only have access to if I
give you a point you can evaluate the
value of the distribution so it will be
you know very high here and not very
high here um if you have the gradient
you can get the value and you can also
get an arrow that points you towards the
the maximum um so that would be the
gradient um and if you have access to
that you can already see how that helps
you simulate Dynamics um and get points
that because the gradient is pointing
you to high likelihood regions it helps
you do the the sampling a bit more
efficiently um so it all depends on um
on if when you wrote this function this
P that you're evaluating if you do it if
you did in a differentiable way which uh
which may not be trivial if you have I
don't know step functions and
things is that does that make
sense yeah so I mean again it doesn't
apply to discrete problems you canot
take gradients there but in this case um
you can actually I think the animation
actually has gradient the the other one
def has gradients um no it doesn't again
so here you can imagine um in one
setting if I pick a point here I can
evaluate P of X um and the other setting
I can not only evaluate P of X but also
the gradient of P of X which again will
be an arrow pointing in this case the
maximum is here so if I'm here it will
be an arrow pointing that way if I'm
here it'll be an arrow pointing that way
and so on um so that gradient will give
me information about where I should how
I should generate the new samples um but
that's not something before you had
before you had differentiable
programming you never had access to that
and even now you may or may not have
been able to write it in a
differentiable
way maybe you guys are you know used to
always having gradients but my first M
was in Fortran 90 so there was
definitely no gradients there
um this there's one more S I
think um I imagine that uh depending on
your proposal distribution that um
sequential elements of a chain will be
dependent on each other yeah um yeah
that's that's a very good point that I I
kind of conveniently skipped yeah um so
there's something called the the auto
correlation time and so on so basically
yes you if you're proposal is too close
you will get points that are too
correlated and that's bad and you can
solve it but ideally you just try to
generate enough points that that's not
an issue but
yes or heuristics that you guys normally
use I I mean you can you there's actual
calculations you can do on on the kind
of self correlation of your chains um
and you can remove intermediate points
to to to decrease the self correlation
um but it's yeah I can point you to to
literature if you actually have to I
should have actually probably added a
slide on that yeah
thanks uh following up on this I expect
that if you have multiple workers they
will be independent right I mean they
could they could be independent multiple
that's another good point to do Gman
ruin the multiple workers have to be
unor related um there are
implementations including some very
famous public ones that use information
of all the Walkers to propose points so
that means that you can no longer use
Gman Ruben because that assumes it
dependent Walkers um but normally if
your proposal is random then they are
entirely uncorrelated yeah if if if
there's no interaction between the
workers and you're just sampling in
parallel then I assume then they're
entirely uncorrelated yeah and that's a
condition to use govern Ruben actually I
should have mentioned that they have to
be
uncorrelated
maybe I also ask one question you
mentioned that like there are some
problems which are easy to solve with
with simpler method like nested sampling
and we don't need to use jonet and I'm
actually curious what are the problems
where uh nestling and mcmc really
doesn't work and we need Nets yeah
that's a very good question so I mean I
think the nice thing about gifton Nets
is that it's such a flexible framework
right so like you have your application
but then Tristan talks about like fosil
learning and all these things which mcmc
I mean maybe if you really think about
it you might be but it's really hard to
to use it for multiple things from a
pure sampling perspective mcmc struggles
with multimodal things but if you do
have something like HMC it actually goes
to high Dimensions so it's multimodality
that kills you um if you have nested
sampling multimodality is no longer an
issue but but scaling because you're
compressing in this way basically your
the amount of compression steps you need
will scale badly with dimensionality so
in our paper we took it to like a few
hundreds to like about a thousand
Dimensions but we haven't like it's hard
to take it beyond that although it's
still something we maybe trying to think
about maybe with the help of G flets or
something like that um but yeah so mcmc
struggle with multimodality nested
sampling with very high dimens like
image kind of Dimensions or
above thank
you one more
question
is there any sampling method that they
we use like natural gradients and that
you use what sorry natural gradient like
second order like second order gradients
not that I know of um that's a good
question not that I know of um you
probably could use that I
mean I mean there might be I wouldn't
claim to know that there's a lot of
sampling literature but not any that I'm
aware
of that' be a stupid question but if for
like both methods that require gradients
do we assume that we know the P ofx that
we want to sample from yes that's a
throughout this talk we're assuming we
know PX we have access to pox so we've
learned it or it has been given to us or
we we know pox because that's not always
the case no that's not the case like
what's the alternative I mean you have
two options you either separately learn
P of X with like an energy based model
or something like that and then you go
back to this or you try to do it all in
one go with something like a diffusion
model or normalizing flow and then you
try to learn pox sample from it in one
go um but this is assuming you know
P okay let's thank pabl
again and we continue with our next
session on sing with reinforcement
learning and is going to be presented by
p p is a graduate student with d frob
and yeah very happy to have you here the
floor is yours P thank
you
hi everyone uh my name is pad and I'll
give you uh in this part of the workshop
I'll give you a brief introduction to
reinforcement learning and its
application uh to
sampling um so what is uh what is uh
reinforcement learning uh what kind of
problem does it solve um reinforcement
learning is for solving sequential
decision making problems uh based on
interaction so let's say in this example
here uh we have an agent it's like robot
our agent here interacts uh with the
environment to its
actions and then um the agent receives
some feedback from the environment in
the form of reward and its observation
so the action will change the state of
the environment and uh with transition
to the new state and the reward would be
some scalar value that shows how good uh
the actions
are and uh basically the goal of this
agent would be to maximize uh the reward
so we will learn to this interactive
Loop uh how to uh take better and better
actions so um I'll give an example here
um uh it's our agent here would be a dog
uh and the dog uh what's the goal of a
dog uh tries to maximize the chance of
receiving
treats um so the people who have dog
probably are more familiar with this
problem uh the actions in this setting
would be different muscle contractions
that a dog can
take and the dog will learn based on
this interactive loop with the
environment uh basically it's owner uh
that the certain muscle contractions
leading to sitting would lead to
receiving the
reward so our agent the dog uh will
learn
this so uh now a more serious example uh
would be uh basically a cool application
of reinforcement learning uh for some
real world problems uh such as drug
Discovery so in this setting uh
basically uh the we are trying to change
some amino acids in a
peptide and to this action we'll try to
interact with the environment the
environment being our petri
dish um so in this example let's say our
peptide uh needs to have some
antimicrobial properties and this
circles would show the basically the can
you see yeah the circles will show the
uh basically bacterial
colonies so when we interact with this
environment we add this peptides to this
culture uh we aim to see how this the
state of the culture would change and we
see the observation which is the new
state and the reward would be let's say
how effective uh the peptide was in
inhibiting the bacterial
growth so through this interactive Loop
we can learn uh what type of peptide we
add to this uh culture to receive our
desired uh basically biological property
maximize let's say
antimicrobial uh efficiency here the
potency uh so this was one real board
example we can go back we're going to go
back again to this at the end of the
presentation so now to solve this
problem we need to formalize it uh and
that will be through defining the mark
of decision process so first as we saw
throughout the day we heard about Mark
of chain which Mark of chain we have a
state and a transition operator and we
have this Mark of property basically
that uh our next state only depend on
the current state so it's like we forget
about the
history and then uh we'll see in our
Mark of decision
process we have States we have actions
and transition operator uh which
basically are next state not only depend
on our current state but also it depend
on some
action and uh the reward would be uh
when we go to the next State uh what
would be the reward when going next
State open uh receive an
action so the reward here is some scalar
value and uh
here we will see the goal of basically
reinforcement learning that was a
problem formulation now the goal of a
reinforcement learning uh agent so our
objective is basically to find an
optimal policy which
maximizes the cumulative uh sum of
rewards so uh what is a policy is policy
T tells us what action to take at a
certain State uh reward is a scalar
feedback that tells us how well that
action was at a certain
State and here we are taking our
expectations with respect to the
trajectory this trajectory is a sequence
of state and actions uh which we can see
in this graphical model that like next
State uh depend on the current state and
action and uh our policy gives us the
probability of taking certain action at
a certain State okay and the probability
of this sequence of states and action is
defined by uh product of our transition
probability by our
policy so that's was the goal of uh
reinforcement learning agent um and
we'll go back to this a lot of time
through this presentation you'll
see so one algorithm to solve
reinforcement learning problems is
called Q learning Q learning is an
example of a value based
method so we saw again the our objective
was to find a policy that maximizes the
expected future rewards and if we find
our Q value as the expected uh sum of
future reward then finding an uh optimal
Q value uh when we find that uh we can
basically derive our optimal policy from
that by taking the AR
Max so um in this algorithm uh the
optimal Q will satisfy the bman
optimality equation and we see how we
use that as an update
rule um in this uh studo code we see the
Q learning algorithm basically this in
an interactive
fashion that um at a certain State we
take action in most naive way would be
basically taking the greedy action
taking an action that maximizes the
these Q values okay
uh we interact with the environment we
receive reward and then we go to the
next state and then we update the Q
values so our next uh estimate of the Q
value would be our current estimate plus
uh this TD
error so a good intuitive way to think
about this CD error is that uh we are
trying to basically uh learning guesses
based on guesses so thinking that all
the future let's say action from now
would be
optimal uh eventually we try to
basically our TD error should go to zero
and that goes to zero when we find our
uh optimal Q with uh which basically uh
fits into this uh bman optimality
equation um so going back again to like
what what we saw in this algorithm is
that uh we interact with the environment
we generate an action uh we receive a
reward go to the next state and we
update our Q values and then we up we
improve our policy by taking the argmax
of the Q values uh and then this Loop
repeats uh so one important thing in
this uh problem is uh tra trade off of
exploration and exploitation as we said
that one naive way to uh find an act
action is to take the greedy action okay
uh but what other things that we can
what are other things that we can do
here um because let's say if we always
take the grey action uh there could be
some part of this statea space that we
never explore and that could be
problematic uh basically because maybe
those states that we never visited were
leading to high rewards and because we
never visited we would not know so we
should have some strategy to balance
this tradeoff so one way that Q learning
deals with that
uh the most simple uh method is called
Epsilon greedy Epsilon greedy what does
it do is that it says with probability
Epsilon take the random action and with
probability one minus Epsilon take that
VD
action okay and so again I want to
highlight that encouraging exploration
is important because sometimes taking uh
suboptimal action could lead to
eventually a high
reward
so we saw that was like one method uh to
encourage exploration uh
behavior um another framework is called
maximum entropy
RL again going back to the uh RL
objective the standard RL the objective
is we're trying to maximize uh the
expected sum of future
rewards okay but what if we augment this
reward with the entropy term so the
optimal policy that we will learn not
only will maximize this reward we also
maximize its entropy at the visited
state so that would be good that this
way the policy will learn some
exploratory Behavior so this framework
is called Maxum entropy oral framework
and the benefits of this would be a
better exploratory Behavior which is
especially important in multimodal
problems better pre-training for later
adaptation of the policy and for robust
re reward control
problems uh which could be uh basically
our policy would be robust to
perturbation to the reward
function so these are some benefits of
uh basically uh using this uh objective
to derive the optimal
policy one algorithm that uh solves
maximum on PRL is called self Q
learning so this is very similar to The
Q learning that we saw before with some
uh changes that we go through so what
did we do we took an uh we at certain
State we take an action uh before our
action let's say in the naive way was
taking the greedy action but here we
would sample our action with respect to
the softmax of the Q values and then we
interact same way like before uh with
the environment we rece reward going to
the next state and in the update State
um Step In instead of taking the max we
will take the Lo sux which is a uh
basically this is a soft relaxation of
the Max uh the same way AR sof Max the
soft acction of AR
Max so basically uh this algorithm uh
solves the maximum entropy RL objective
that we saw in the previous
slide so now uh we will see uh what can
be use this this algorithm for some
application of Maximum entropy RL could
be for sampling in this example I will
give you uh an example of sampling
peptides in Auto regressive fashion
where our action space consist of 20
amino
acids our state space is the sequence of
amino acid of Maximum four and our
objective would be to generate
biologically plausible peptides of
length form
so what do we do uh we start from an
empty uh string we add one amino acid
like second third and then when we reach
the length four uh we basically evaluate
the reward and each peptide is
associated with a reward which let's say
in our example that we saw in the
beginning could be antimicrobial uh
property of
it so we say that if you find the
optimal policy uh solving maximum
entropy RL objective then following this
policy we'll sample the peptides the
objects that we want with probability
proportional to the exponential of the
reward okay so in this example as we saw
uh we sampling basically in some order
like in Auto regressive function we are
building a sample but what if there was
like no order in like basically uh
building our sample let's say an example
uh it's like building a smiley face um
which we add the mouth the
eyebrows uh and at the end we make a
image of a smiley face so in this case
it might not matter like first adding
the mouth and then the eyebrow the final
image might be the same so what what's
the problem with this is that let's say
in this case okay we add the mouth and
then the eyebrow and then eyebrow then
the mouth but we will see that the final
result is the same so there are multiple
ways to actually reach a certain state
so what do we do like here you'll see
that Maxim actually doesn't gives us the
correct sample as then sample
proportionally to the exponential
reward okay so the how to solve this is
to
basically we will learn in the next days
of the uh Workshop there's an algorithm
called G flet which basically address
the limitation of uh the maximum onop
URL for this class of
problems and uh yeah with that uh I'll
finish this
presentation and thank you everyone for
listening thank you so much P do we have
any questions
yes please
Lena thank you for the presentation so
here what does it simple proportionally
to if it's not exponential of our uh so
it's sample if I break yeah so uh in
this case what does Max inop RL sample
proportional to if it's not exponential
of R is it like the number of trajectory
multiplied by exponential of r or uh so
yeah the maximum entropy RL samples uh
with respect to the exponential of the
reward but when we have like the order
like the order here being let's say Auto
regressively adding one piece of our
sample uh but in this case because there
are like multiple ways to to reach that
then there's it's like biased the
problem so the sample that we will
receive with maximum onop RL objective
would be a biased sample it's not
correct okay and we don't know what is
the reward in this case so the reward
would be log of exponential of
R this is basically the reward
right yeah okay maybe my question wasn't
clear but like if you don't have an
order I mean if you can have any order
What's um what will the policy be in I
mean what will the reward be in the end
for for if you train with Max entropy AR
but maybe my question doesn't make sense
okay the reward is basically we are
using Max like the point is that we are
not sampling correctly with respect to
the something that we want which is
exponential of the reward but yeah we
can maybe talk more and understand
better the question thank
you any other
questions so you mentioned um like some
techniques to do exploration so excellon
Grady and maximum entropy RL are there
any other things other than these two
techniques to do exploration in RL that
we can use to like like improve some
like U some possible future rewards okay
uh that's a good question um so I think
yeah there there is other methods uh
basically uh one way would be like
changing this like bonus here like uh uh
this bonus like I said uh in this case
would be the entropy of the policy maybe
we want to like induce novalty uh but um
yeah there are different methods to
induce this exploratory
Behavior could be from some prior uh
inducing dis Behavior through prior
or
um thank you for your presentation I
have a question respect to the EM work
briefly um so we know that biological
sequences like for instance if you're
looking at uh antimicrob PTI like the
position for instance is important
because it might help you to better
understand the structure 3D or 2D now in
case I have two sequences that have the
same reward how do I
choose which one for instance to
prioritize or
consider um so in this case when we had
uh let's
say this is smiley face he's like
exactly the same smiley face right yes
uh
so like your question is that I mean in
the basically the way we are doing this
uh peptides would be in autoaggressive
fashion so we won't have that problem
anymore right because there's like
ordering but because it's like a tree
and there is like ordering right but
like in this case there it's not a tree
anymore so this is like where the
problem starts so like the way we solve
the uh peptide problem was in this
fashion so are you saying it cannot
happen that you have for instance two
different sequences with the same words
score now are you is it what you're
saying because I'm assuming it could
happen right so if it happens and I know
both sequences are different but they
have the same reward for instance if I
want to select like new generated peptid
to see which one maybe I'm sending to
wet lab experiment which one do I choose
if I have two sequences of many which
have the same reward I see so the way we
sample is that it's proportional to that
reward so they're going to be sampled
similarly uh the way I think about it
and then they're going to be sent to the
wlb
so I think that's the way could be one
way thank you is there anyone else any
other
questions
okay then let's let's thank P
again yeah and uh with this we're going
to finish today's day Victor do you want
to say something so we're a bit early so
it's pretty unusual so enjoy that
there's uh still some coffee left and uh
we'll see you tomorrow morning with
opening words from yoshu are motivating
gonets and we'll get into the to the
core of where where you're here thank
you one M there's also leftover from um
the lunch so if you are hungry or if you
think you will be hungry later in the
day feel free to grab some food uh
otherwise we will uh let it to everyone
at M so help
yourself